Vladimir Putin has issued his ultimatum
that European nations unfriendly Nations
not just Europe must start paying for
oil from Russia in Rubles but not just
that they have to open Russian bank
accounts and handle their exchange
through the Russian Financial system
this is something that is is missing
from many of the headlines because
they're making it sound like Vladimir
Putin's just saying look look buy rubles
first
when in reality he's actually saying you
can still pay us in Euro but it has to
go through our financial system first
why Western sanctions hurting the
Russian economy and this is Vladimir
Putin's way of saying we're going to
strike back not only that they're
pegging the ruble to gold and instantly
the ruble recovers so Western sanctions
fail Vladimir Putin now has tremendous
leverage over Europe and everyone is
kind of panicking about whether or not
he'll shut off gas tomorrow European
nations are calling his bluff saying
nice try we're not going to play these
games in Germany they're saying this is
blackmail we'll see who caves first
because tomorrow is the deadline April
1st how amazing would it be if tomorrow
Vladimir Putin comes out and goes on a
pub public address and he's like I
warned you all I would shut off your gas
and April Fools everybody was just
kidding he's like you know it was just a
joke yeah I mean so so hold on you're
telling me they've uh they've lost
McDonald's isn't marketing there anymore
the big Banks left and they went back to
the gold standard
s
1980s called that's horrible that's
horrible all right everybody uh so we're
gonna talk about that and a whole bunch
of other stuff I guess Maxine Waters
yelling at homeless people to go home
and they yell back we don't have homes
that's just funny I guess it's funny sad
but uh joining us to talk about all this
is Brian Nichols what's up Tim how are
you doing I'm good who are you who am I
I'm the host of the Brian Nichols show
I'm a sales executive and uh my role in
this greater Liberty world has been to
take the ideas that we'd like to talk
about all day long and make us your
average person will actually want to pay
attention and actually buy the ideas
versus just hearing this old man yells
at Cloud so uh yeah bring in a little
bit of the sales and marketing world the
Liberty Movement absolutely I prefer to
yell at Clouds so does Joe Biden but
yeah here we are but but when I yell at
a cloud you can understand what I'm
saying I'm not saying
uh but no I'm Seamus Coughlin I run a
YouTube channel called Freedom Tunes we
create short satirical and educational
cartoons released one a week we released
one today as a matter of fact about the
uh transgender Sports issue and how the
sort of milk toast conservative ink
response is inadequate I I think it's uh
funnier than I just explained it so you
guys go check it out I think you'll
enjoy it I was also yelling at Clouds
earlier but with my mind uh there was a
big thunderstorm coming I was like not
tonight so I went up there and I
dispersed the clouds above me no you
were thinking I was thinking I did that
yeah I was thinking hard I was thinking
very very uh
articulately yeah I just I want to point
out real quick too for for many of you
who don't know I actually am the voice
of Dr Anthony fauci on freedom and I I
I've been auditioning for Nancy Pelosi
so I'm really hoping we're hoping he
gets it it's a good impression I mean if
you want to do it right
Beyond yourself look if you want to give
away your secret sauce the whole
audience is going to be able to do the
impression now you've lost it it's good
good yeah why not spread it hey you know
what maybe maybe we got some Nancy
Pelosi every cartoon's coming everyone's
gonna love my Pelosi and they're going
to say you should well they love it as
much as you're fouchy oh I don't know
it's a tough one yeah really good the
fauci is what keeps them that's too real
honestly it does scary yep
um Ian you want to finish your intro
yeah I love you perfect I love that
thing that's wonderful I didn't want to
cut Ian off but I'm also here in the
corner people make fun of me because I
say I'm excited about our guests but I'm
am every single night stoked to have
Brian
thanks Lydia before we get started my
friends head over to
strongerbonesandlife.com to secure your
ageless multi-collagen at 51 off from
BioTrust you need collagen people I know
how old you guys are because I'm the
same age we look at we look at our
audience demographics and it's like a
whole lot of 30 year olds well it's like
25 to 34 whatever so if your knees are
starting to go out you want better
brighter skin joint hair nails all that
stuff you got it you got to put this
stuff in your drink man you can mix in
your coffee it's really good actually
and uh you know I've got a half pipe in
my basement so I skate a whole lot I'm
not trying to Humble break I guess but
no like I'm just trying to point out I
skate a whole lot so I'm taking my knees
very seriously because that's that's it
I know so many people who've busted
their ACLS and if you want to be able to
exercise and Carry On Through uh through
life as you get older which is important
strongerbones in life.com and they say
you will get a 60-day money-back
guarantee the healthy aging support of
collagen in its ideal forms the five key
types of collagen you need from four
different sources for every order today
they will donate a nutritious meal to a
hungry child in your honor through their
partnership with no kid honey angry.org
to date BioTrust has provided over 5
million meals to Hungry kids police help
BioTrust hit their goal of 6 million
meals this year it is non-GMO and free
of artificial colors flavors
preservatives and sweeteners and free of
gluten antibiotics and rbgh and RBST
nearly no odor or taste unlike bone
broth there's no clumping unlike other
supplements you'll get free shipping
with every order and free VIP live
health and fitness coaching from
biotrust's Team of expert nutrition and
health coaches for life with every order
in their free e-report the 14 foods for
amazing skin with every water for with
every order
um the skin is important you know you
want to look young me I'm all about the
knees you got to keep the knees nice and
strong so you can keep jumping off
buildings into your old age at least
that's my plan my dad was in his 70s and
started getting cuts that weren't
healing started taking collagen he said
he's noticed something you see there you
go don't get lacerations and and
whatever so go to
strongerbonesinlife.com and Shout out
bio trust thank you very much but don't
forget head over to timcast.com become a
member to support our work directly and
you'll get access to the exclusive
episodes on the four members only on the
website we have those up Monday through
Thursday at 8 pm we will have one for
you all tonight and and as a member you
are supporting all of our journalists
who are reporting the news every single
day it's their job and they're all very
grateful that you keep them gainfully
employed so don't forget to smash that
like button subscribe to this channel
share the show with your friends right
now take that URL posted everywhere and
let's read the big scary War News BBC
reports Russia threatens to stop
supplying gas if not paid in Rubles I
don't I don't like these headlines I
scoured Google for a headline that was
actually getting into nitty-gritty but
it's more than that Vladimir Putin has
signed a decrease stating buyers must
open Ruble accounts in Russian banks
that is very different nobody sells
anything for free and we're not going to
do charity either Putin's demand is
being seen as attempt to boost the ruble
which has been hit by Western sanctions
well it's working the ruble is
recovering but this is more about
Russia's Banks they say his decree means
foreign buyers of Russian gas would have
to open an account at Russia's gas prom
bank and transfer Euros or US dollars
into it gasprom bank would then convert
this into rubles which will then be used
to make the payment for gas he's not
saying you have to buy the oil and gas
he's saying you have to open an account
and put your money into it he's propping
up the Russian Financial system because
of Western sanctions he's now got the
mere payment system visa and MasterCard
and Amex and all these companies
suspending he didn't care all Joe Biden
has done with his sanctions is bolster
Russia and make them fiercely
independent strong and weaken the U.S
Us's position around the world so um
thanks Joe Biden I can't believe that's
something Joe Biden intended to do had
the reverse effect this is unbelievable
to me because he said you know but this
is what they say about smooth talkers
you know you can't trust them it's got
that silver tongue but the follow
through just isn't there yeah it's not
it's it's it's it's also that he's he
tries to walk back or claim things never
happened
none of that happened well this with the
sanctions I think he was asked by Ducey
he's like the only journalist asking
questions he was asked you know these
sanctions were supposed to deter Putin
and they're not and then it was one of
the spokespeople for the administration
they're like no no we never said that oh
no I think Biden himself but he actually
doesn't remember bro go easy on him he's
like I didn't say that man alone that
was a very telling video Ducey brought
up three things he said that was a
different one okay I'm saying he was
asked specifically you said sanctions
were going to deter Putin he's like well
no I didn't and then there you there's
quotes from the Biden admin where they
were like the sanctions will deter Putin
and they didn't it's you know what it is
it's like blinken and Kamala and uh uh
Biden are like The Three Stooges and
they're slipping around on banana peels
and
Putin's just going off and doing
whatever he wants man you say something
once on the internet video it's there
forever essentially I mean not forever
but uh I don't think he understands that
because he's from an old generation
before the internet right right like
remember when Hillary Clinton put on a
Southern accent when she was in like
Alabama hot sauce oh the hot sauce one
too and two uh Breakfast Club yeah what
do you always keep in your back hot
sauce
because she didn't she didn't realize
that people record everything these days
she's old right yeah back in the day you
could show up anywhere and speak however
you wanted AOC even did it you know
remember she she put on like an uh like
an urban Latina accent or dialect or
whatever and then she was like that's
just how I talk it's like we hear you on
on PBS we hear you on CNN like I said
you don't talk that way right it's so
it's it's creepy but you know what you
get it you're a sales guy right oh yeah
well she's trying to reflect the people
she's talking to but at the same point
in time here comes a fine line between
being your authentic self and being
condescending and I mean we talk about
Joe Biden Hillary Clinton AOC Nancy
Pelosi if there's one thing that they
all represent it's condescension you
know what it is yeah it's like um it's
like the the upper middle class lady who
orders something at a Mexican restaurant
in broken English because she like
assumes that's
sentences please don't yeah you're like
please stop doing this like they're not
even trying to speak Spanish they're
just speaking English poorly
intentionally it's like what are you
doing yo Senor yo necesito
literally do broken is like I want
food for plate you're like bro you can
just talk normally like they'll
understand you remember that Yale study
that's white liberals talk down they
they dumb down their the way they speak
to black people and conservatives don't
that's the crazy yo like here's the
thing I don't dumb down my speech to
anyone because like it can't get any
Dumber for me personally but these
Liberals are just so smart they have to
condescend down to the rest of us the
CDC is calling me right now should I
answer it oh yes the Center for Disease
that's probably definitely a legitimate
commentation that's probably the CDC
yeah should I it says CDC national
immune it's your show I'm just saying
I'm not along for the ride hold on I'm
gonna try to answer this uh hello I am I
am live broadcasting right now is this a
CDC we're live streaming on the internet
uh uh yeah
it is it is it's actually the 60. uh
we're doing a live uh talk show right
now just so you know they're like you
know everyone's able to hear what you
say are you okay with that
yeah okay all right that's probably that
that would probably be better otherwise
we've got you know you know a lot of
people who are watching
all right thanks man yeah call back
later what is a CDC doing a survey for
uh you you heard that yeah did you like
our uh did you like our services the
last couple years what do you think what
did you think of the advice that we were
giving the public scale of one to ten
how much do you trust the CDC today how
satisfied are you
yeah if your tax Dollar's been going to
the right spot yeah maybe not they've
actually been calling me a lot and then
and then if you answer no you take the
survey and you answer that you're not
satisfied they're like this guy's sick
we got to quarantine this one like round
them up and come out with like the
hazmat suits like they're in China you
jump out the window they grab you bring
it back in yeah they call me at 3 51.
they called me let's see let's see 351
today uh 320 today they called me
yesterday what they were trying to reach
you about your vaccines extended
warranty bro that's really weird I don't
think they've called me at all did you
guys get that here by the way like
people go around door to door asking if
you you got your vacs no no that was a
thing in Philly and it was weird this
guy like he comes up to my house and my
wife and I just moved out of
Philadelphia and he knocks on the door
he's like hi sir I'm from the city of
Philadelphia and I'm just going around
to check how people are doing during
covid see if uh you know obviously you
had the opportunity to get your vaccine
I'm like
don't really want to answer that
question he goes well did you get your
vaccine I'm like okay well that's what
they're that's what they're calling for
100 so so I got a text message from them
uh none of it was a voicemail as a
voicemail and uh what did they say I
thought it was a scam to be honestly
messing around yeah they said I'm
calling on behalf of the CDC conducting
a national immunization survey about uh
vaccinations for covet and other
diseases please call us back or whatever
and they called me well uh CDC if you
call me I just want to let you let you
know it will be live yes and so that's
uh your decision what up CDC I have so
many questions anyway we're talking
about you know what's going on in Europe
and then the CDC called me during the
show I I get I get phone calls
periodically during the show I don't
answer them CDC calls oh yeah I thought
it was really interesting because like
is there a new disease did a new new
variant drop one of those it was like I
heard you were doing my voice in these
cartoons I am sending you a cease and
desist I should be the one in making
those royalties off of my own likeness
yeah but yeah uh I didn't actually think
anybody'd be able to hear it but um that
was awesome you know I asked them if
they were okay with it they said no no
no respectable I guess such as but I I
didn't know what they were calling for
so I thought it'd be interesting you
know we'd do a show we talking about
this stuff um but where were we we're
rubles
part of the reason
part of the reason why the ruble bounded
back not only did they set up on gold
but it's it's its value is calculated in
relative to the dollar so if the dollar
drops in value the ruble's gonna go up
relatively in value so as the dollar
keep continues to plummet as it's
continued to be printed you're going to
see all of these other currencies going
up it's actually it's actually a really
good point
um everybody's looking at the ruble
going back up and they're assuming it's
all of these things Putin is doing it
could just be all the things Biden is
doing destroying the dollar oh literally
that's true Biden the FED yeah across
the board it's been a blast like there's
no real is there an independent way to
measure the value of your currency up
against something
well when MasterCard visa and all these
companies pull out of Russia and
that's another part of it so it is
difficult they put them in a corner they
say if you don't you're gonna you know
we're gonna buy your oil with with Euros
but we can shut off your Euro Accounts
at any moment like why would he take
that deal I don't think he's doing
anything out of the ordinary
no I'm not saying I love it I'm just
saying when you look at what the the
Biden Administration has done from a
foreign policy standpoint we were
talking about this beforehand like it
has been one unforced mitigated disaster
after another and I think it's just a
matter of and it's sad to say but I
think Putin looks at it as he just he
has to maintain himself long enough to
outlast Biden and these failed policies
until you're and we're seeing this right
now your average person's like this is
this is not worth it I I I mean maybe
but I also think as soon as Joe Biden
got elected you know you know you know
how they would do they would do the show
The West Wing where it's like that that
camera in front of them as they walk and
then it turns the corner so imagine that
with Putin and and then you know his
guy's like so Joe Biden is President you
have four years and then he's like let's
move and then they start like nailing
out all their plans like we're on the
clock people we got four years to get
this done because as soon as Biden's out
you're gonna get a Donald Trump or
Rhonda Sanchez or something so Putin
knows the iron is hot now is his chance
it's like The Purge for all of our
potential foreign adversaries we have
like a small window where we can do
whatever
once every 100 years the US election
Buchanan or uh or a Biden you think
Biden's gonna run again I hear that he
is
come on man dude I walk again
oh you literally run again no he's not
gonna do that again
holding his hand without stem cells or
something maybe he's a PRP
all right all right
if Joe Biden were to run for president
for a second term yeah it would not be
possible it can't work the first time
around Joe Biden was calling a lid every
week he was sleeping in his basement or
something to that effect and he could
get away with it with coven but I that
was the that was the reason he didn't
have to go out but I think I think you
guys are under underestimating how
appealing he is to the American people
he's a Sly devil the way he sounds the
way he speaks
yeah I've never like been close to him
close enough to touch his hands like the
mung beans or something you know you
know you don't want to be because uh Ian
I got to be honest if if you were at an
event and Joe Biden saw you from behind
yeah with your lawn you don't need to
finish that statement
I'm okay with where you were headed I
know exactly where I'm going what's the
next story no no think about graphene
think about graphene I might have to
change my Twitter profile I've got Biden
smelling me from behind on my Twitter
profile page he's like it's Corn Pop
he's back think about how funny it would
be though like Biden would go up behind
Ian and then grab this child doesn't go
you're not and then but then Ian would
be like yo yo I'm a guy in the Bible be
like I know I know
your long leg hair oh no yeah he's
rubbing your legs
astral project out of his body yeah okay
but in all seriousness uh in in in 2020
there were a lot of excuses about why
Biden should have run why he could win I
didn't buy him but a lot of people were
just they really hated Trump well now a
lot of people really hate Joe Biden his
approval rating is loads to ever been
MSNBC is like despite the booming
economy people you know people don't
like Joe Biden but but imagine Joe Biden
running again against who that's why I'm
like honestly don't give him Trump give
him DeSantis yes give him the Santos
because like they they hated Trump
because he was Trump people dislike or
hate Biden because of what his policies
have been doing to them directly and
that right there is the difference
whereas if you had Ron DeSantis run you
get rid of everything about Trump that
people hate and now instead you can
focus on the policies that people loved
in Florida and people fled to in mass in
Florida because they were trying to get
away like I did from Philadelphia of the
crazy leftist policies oh you're in
Florida now no
I think about it though
Trump should run because we're at the
point now where I'm pretty sure enough
people are gonna look at Biden and Trump
and go I'm not making that same mistake
twice yeah and then not only do you get
Trump back in office to be the Raging
Bull storming through the ivy Tower but
you could say I told you so to all of
those people who turn around and said
yeah can we make a mistake with that one
see I I look at DeSantis though because
whether in like the whole don't don't
say gay bill which isn't actually a bill
that says Parental can't say don't say
gay right
um he was smart in the way he put that
bill into place because he is making the
left now responding kind to him and say
we want to teach our kids this in school
and your average parent is like you're
teaching what to my K through third
grader no I don't think so whereas Trump
would just go out and be like what's the
headline for the day what can I go after
and smash with a hammer and now and now
we have a chance to put something like
JFK a little bit yeah now we have a
chance to put um Rhonda Santos in front
where he could have the chance to lead
on policy and get and get the
progressive left to answer that I I'd
rather have to stand us to be completely
honest because of what the new the
latest news that he's calling a special
legislative session to the redistricting
uh no for congression uh for
constitutional carrying oh okay jeez wow
so Rhonda Santos was like yeah we're
gonna do a special session come in vote
on everyone being able to carry guns
without permits and you just buy and
conceal and everything and it's just
like you didn't have to do that I
already liked you yeah but I like this a
lot so bring that to the federal
government I'd love to see him be like
as president you know one of my agenda
items for this is uh uh repealing the
NFA imagine if he came out and he just
issued a executive order moratorium on
ATF action against NFA items I don't
know if you'd go that far
but you know I let's tell him to do it
yeah in all honestly Ron if you're
listening I mean the CDC called you
anything's possible somebody somebody
said I should have answered the phone as
Dr
[Laughter]
faucially
I'll be there
overseas right now are you wearing your
masks uh my concern with the santis is
that the media is on a started their
smear campaign against them now with
this don't say gay crap
um but it's not that they haven't done
with Trump so it's like not any worse
but they try to do it with him during
covid too and and yes and it failed like
they really tried to make DeSantis look
like he had four heads he was gonna kill
grandma and and that the state was going
to burn into flames and yet that's a
good point you even had AOC partying
maskless in Florida right everybody can
see that the progressives and the
Democrats are being led by Hypocrites
and Liars
yeah I mean you're gonna have people and
and look the media can propagandize the
public all they want people are decently
intelligent they're going to notice that
the folks living in the states that
everyone is leaving are telling you not
to vote for the guy who ran the state
everyone has been trying to move too and
uh to your point Brian Ian I would or I
guess to Ian's point but bouncing off
what Brian said a moment ago you're
correct that the media started a smear
campaign against them with the the
parental rights and education bill but
all they did was make themselves look
really bad especially at the Oscars
they they
brilliant play from the from the
Republicans on this one the parental
rights and education bill says no secret
conversations no withholding medical
information and no uh specific sex ed
kind of talk for kindergarten to third
grade and uh the the initial uh bill on
the website said Pre-K but the bill
itself says kindergarten so there's a
bit of a confusion there we were saying
Pre-K for a while I checked the actual
language of the bill says kindergarten
so that's a correction but also the dot
florida.gov website does say Pre-K so I
don't know where that where that split
is coming from but imagine now you look
at the tweets like David Hogg tweeted
this where he was like here's a quote
from the bill sounds like don't say gay
to me and I'm just like but that quote
you posted also prohibits straight
discussions as well and I'm just like I
don't understand why these people are so
hell-bent on having sex conversations
with children
it's such a weird thing to look for in a
bill too you hear there's a parental
rights Bill they're like but is this
going to make it more difficult to have
conversations with children in secret
about uh gay sex like we need to make
sure we need to make sure that that's
not the case otherwise it's just a
massive violation of our rights but the
crazy part is it's not about gay
it's about literally any anything yes
exactly you can't you can't go in
Florida to a classroom and be like
mommies and daddies love each other and
get married ah nope you can't do that
this bill prevents that and the people
who supported it most people support it
because they're like yeah that makes
sense that's big to me though when you
see the polling showing that it's like
what is it 60 some odd percent supported
the parental rights and education bill
with the horrendous framing yep it means
people are starting to break through the
lies which is kind of why I'd love to
see a trump Biden rematch DeSantis I
think is better in a lot of ways to be
completely honest but uh he is I mean
he's younger he's he's more in I think
he's more in tune
um this constitutional carry thing
that's just so fantastic but what he's
doing with Florida is just wonderful and
people are chatting being like don't
take him away from us in Florida yeah
but that's actually really interesting
no that's a really interesting governor
of Florida yeah
how much better and and granted I am not
downplaying the necessity of having the
right person in the Oval Office but I do
think there is something to be said for
this idea that DeSantis is really
extremely powerful in Florida and
imagine how much better this country
would be if other political leaders just
followed suit and behaved like him in
their states if Republican governors in
other parts of the country actually had
some guts and developed a spine and
stood up for their people the way Ron
DeSantis has the country would be so I
mean I think that would do more good for
the country than even a DeSantis
presidency was he's got balls yeah is
New York ending the vax mandates now I
just heard that I heard they did yes so
that's in that I give it to Santas it's
because of people like him particularly
him that the country has been able to
dodge a proverbial bullet of having to
jab ourselves when now we're
acknowledging that you don't really need
it yep so and he goes and I mean no no
but like this goes back to and I've been
pushing this a lot my program instead of
responding to narratives setting the
narratives like and that's where
DeSantis have been killing it he is not
responding to okay leftist makes a
argument and they're full force and now
conservatives Libertarians anybody right
of Center is now playing defense instead
DeSantis is playing offense we're seeing
Republicans play offense Libertarians
playing offense and now you're seeing
the left scramble because they're not
used to having to actually explain wait
why do you want to teach kids sex when
they're in kindergarten like that wasn't
a secret conversations and have secret
conversations with children right now
now and I have a funnel expression like
they'll use when you're explaining
you're losing the left is explaining now
and now that they're in this this trap
of having to to unwind this massive web
that they have made of just Insanity
your average person and I keep on going
back to the average person because I
think this is who we should be talking
to they're looking at what's happening
and they're like this is insane this
isn't I don't want to teach my my kids
sex when they're in kindergarten like
and even if that's a conversation to
have let me have it let me determine
when that's going to be so all the all
all the more reason why we all like
Rhonda santis and what's happening in
Florida why so many people are moving
there but uh uh just in terms of you
know going back to the original subject
was Joe Biden running we also we need to
consider that if Joe Biden can't run for
president that means the Democrats need
to announce in a month or two that
because they're gonna have to start
setting up their primary candidates yep
so 2023 is primary season and if that's
not going to be Biden could you imagine
Biden trying to campaign he's going to
be 80. yeah so what you're what you're
saying is I need to release all of the
Biden cartoons who've been working on
within like the next month or so before
he's gone yeah yeah you're gonna have
like this really great 12 you know
minute I've been working animation on
Biden no I have a 12-part miniseries on
him hour-long episodes I mean you're
Biden's singing The Greatest Hits got
like how many almost to a million 800
000 yeah yeah he's a lot of fun if not
fine it is sad funny you know what I
mean like it's sad it's dangerous too
that's the thing like it's kind of big I
like poke fun at him I try not to be too
cruel
um because on some level it's you feel
bad for the guy his brain just doesn't
work but at the same time it is really
hysterical that everyone is avoiding
saying that he literally has dementia
first they were saying he had a stutter
now they're saying it's because he's
Irish he says these ridiculous things I
mean regime change in Russia because
he's Irish and so he understands empathy
and I'm like is that like a genetic
Irish thing
I got a brand new shiny helmet
I don't have the same kind of sympathy
for this guy because if you know if you
get behind the wheel of a car for
instance and you're blind and you end up
killing someone I have no secret I hear
you bro I agree with you on that but I
almost think he's to the point where
someone else had to have put him there I
just don't know that he's competent
enough to have made the decision to
place himself in that position it's like
you have something in the backseat of
the car they're like Joe Biden in the
front seat they're like all right
there's a turn up here to the left turn
turn now turn down and he's like what
where tree and he just goes off into the
Ravine but like whose turn is it no but
yeah who turns it anyways Ian I I would
I would agree with you I think my point
is more or less and really what I'm
trying to get at is if this was anyone
else if I were to see any other person
experiencing that kind of cognitive
decline it would just make me it would
make me sad I wouldn't really find much
to poke fun at but because this man is
literally the leader of the country and
everyone's trying to to pretend that
he's not only fit but that he's like the
best they can't just claim that he's
fitted he's like the best president ever
it's a booming economy according to
MSNBC why don't people like him and the
man can't finish a single sentence
without saying something ridiculous or
stamina everyone everyone should imagine
the emperor you know The Emperor's New
Clothes story and it's the Emperor who
ends up walking down the street naked
with everyone pretending like he's not
but now we have social media take that
story in a video of that story again and
replace the emperor with with Biden and
not only is the is the Emperor wearing
no clothes but he's demented and he's
like fumbling about confused and
someone's holding his hand as he goes no
simple information you remove people
like that from Power immediately that is
a danger to our society absolutely
absolutely no he should you imagine yo
yo so they're all like nuclear Wars
coming Russia and everything right and
you know Russia is going to shut off gas
and they're flying planes with nukes on
them could you imagine if Vladimir Putin
is in his nuclear bunker and he's like
and then NATO General is called and
they're like Mr President Russia has
fired an ICBM towards Ukraine should we
retaliate yeah man you know we hit Libya
you know take them out and they're like
Libya sir you know come on man and like
all right I guess you know what Biden's
first reaction would be if he heard that
news he'd be like
oh
it would be disappointment because he's
a lame loser
the 20 man listen when Joe Biden was
talking about Syria back at like the G7
or whatever he kept calling it Libya yep
and I'm like yo people don't people
downplay this when when Peter Ducey was
talk was asking questions to Biden he
said
it seemed like you said this and it
seemed like you said this and but it's
like never happened it's like Biden
you're only lying to yourself because
everyone in the world heard you say it
imagine if he's in private with a
general where should we retaliate uh
Libya man it's like Libya are you sure
are you sure you heard me it's like okay
the president said nuke Libya and then
you're like no no Moscow Joe is a
journalist gonna pop up and go Joe Biden
actually meant to say Moscow oh the
generals then say oh okay okay we'll
change the trajectory I can't allow you
to spread this paranoid misinformation
Joe Biden's geriatric nurse would be
there to let the general know he's
having a senior moment and that he
actually means something else you think
they're sending the man around without a
translator out of your mind
yo I know some old Trump is old and he
has spry yeah it's true the the thing
about Trump is he wouldn't accidentally
tell you to do it the wrong place he'd
tell you to hit Moscow kind of early
he'd be like I know how to deal with it
if he's getting nuke it hit him first
they went into Ukraine sign up before
you very black just in case yeah
no I don't think Trump would have
actually nuked Moscow I'm kidding but
but there's that uncertainty like even
Trump was saying five ten percent you
don't you know this guy's kind of crazy
a ten percent might have done it like I
was thinking I'm not I I was thinking
about it I was I really was
um I wouldn't be surprised if he was
or or he just knows how to do the big
ask and he goes to she and he goes to
Putin and says do it and I'll nuke you
and Joe Biden can only just say come on
man come on or no you don't got a soul
that's what he claims he looked Putin in
the eye and he told that bully you don't
have a soul as if Vladimir Putin is just
this really introspective guy who was
like well if Joe Biden doesn't think I
have soul perhaps it's a good cartoon
you could make though where like in
Biden's mind he's like ripped and he
like wanted to Putin and he's like
listen here Chum you ain't got no soul
no Malarkey and Putin's like Please Mr
Biden please and then like in reality
he's like you so man and then puts like
Foods on the horse he called me a soul
man I'm a soul man that's the thing
Putin but that's like so what he told
him he's mean you told if the foreign
propaganda because we're sitting here
making fun of our president acting like
Putin is not you know but then he
shouldn't act like an idiot maybe if our
president didn't have dementia we would
be making fun of Putin instead and we
may find a trump too
yeah exactly I mean frankly I was
thinking I thought baby today I will hit
the button I don't know think about it
it's just a thought I didn't say I would
do it uh yeah you mentioned something
earlier because you were saying that
Biden will simply say I didn't say that
man yeah even though everyone knows he
did this on camera you made a point
earlier about how that could just be an
issue with members of his generation
they don't expect everything to be
filmed they don't I mean I find with
most public personalities under the age
of 40 when someone calls them out for
something they said they're usually
embarrassed about it or they start to
offer an explanation they won't say I
never said that yeah
didn't know that I said if someone said
you said something and I'm like no I I
don't think so and they're like yes you
did I'd be like okay show me the footage
so I can verify that you're right here
and I would eat it you do have to what
are you gonna do I'm not gonna lie to
people yeah but it's it's not it's just
that joke you'd show Joe Biden the video
and he'd be like what am I looking at
he'd be trying to like look at it and
everything and they'd be like Joe this
is this is you saying you would use
chemical weapons and he goes what no I I
never said that he's gonna go no man
that's a decrease
that's one of them they put your face on
it a deep cake
man I didn't say that I'm gonna I'm
still gonna make fun of Joe Biden after
he's president too that's for sure well
no I mean maybe it'll be less relevant
the left ripped on Reagan decades after
he left office and I remember this joke
they said it over and over again oh how
hilarious how stupid that the
Republicans had a president who was
experiencing cognitive decline it's like
well you guys yeah exactly it's like
well you guys
you guys chose Joe Biden knowing he was
demented he wasn't president like there
was an out and you still picked him yeah
man that's how uh have you seen you guys
see the story that uh um the Army is uh
uh reducing its uh enlistment
expectations yes because the commercial
about having two moms didn't work yeah
exactly well actually let me see if I
can find it you know so uh but anyway my
point is kind of wrapping up the Joe
Biden thing uh I forgot where I was
going with it because now I want to talk
about the the oh I I heard that it's
because of the botched Afghanistan
surrender let's call it a surrender
because that's what it was we
surrendered all 800 billion dollars
worth of equipment today to the enemy
and hastily left a bunch of people there
that that's the reason people are not
signing up for the military now because
they don't trust it well and that's did
you notice that's when things really
changed like the tenor on Biden just
like 180. I don't know what if it was
the Afghanistan withdrawal or the fact
that we left like was 80 billion dollars
worth of Supply
let me pull this thing at this point we
got the story here from Breitbart Army
reducing its numbers in face of
recruiting difficulties they see the
Army this week admitted it was having
problems recruiting and announced an
unprecedented reduction in his number
size that would shrink the active duty
Army to its smallest size since World
War II well that's great apparently uh
uh you've got retired army lieutenant
general Thomas spoer uh saying the Army
has not faced such recruiting headwinds
in the last 30 years I am unaware of a
situation where the Army has cut its end
strength in response to a negative
recruiting Outlook Vladimir Putin just
drafted 134 500 people and the U.S is
drawing down his numbers being like
nobody wants to enlist so uh uh thanks
Joe Biden I guess well and not just Joe
Biden I mean we can definitely attribute
it to him even though it started way
before he was president because what was
it all the way back in 1997 he was
saying he wanted to go to war with Iraq
he's the swamp creature like the rest of
me pushed for all this nonsense and this
is what happens when you go to war
frivolously it's not only a horrifically
and barbarically evil thing to do in and
of itself but of course you undermine
your credibility with the American
people so now when we're at a point in
history where Global tensions really are
heightened we don't really have a
military in order to fight whatever War
might break out and other nations know
that but we got to be uh very serious
and specific here how long ago was the
two moms Army campaign yeah
last year wasn't it and now that clearly
did not work yeah when you recruiting
three moms we need a commercial with
three months more moms yeah more moms
yeah just a whole bunch of moms more is
better a bunch of faster funnier put
enough moms I don't think there was
enough moms in that situation
the Army legitimately ran a campaign
that was all about diversity inclusivity
and Equity die cult stuff and they did
that very famous uh two mums thing
clearly didn't work and it was animated
like a Disney cartoon which was so
strange first of all who listens to a
cartoon right but also I mean if you're
trying to recruit people for the
military why are you making this like
that's the role of the military
I was surprised that like the birds did
like the seagulls didn't fly to the ship
and start going with them and I think
it's fair to say legitimate assessment
the Emma and her two moms has uh has
backfired on the Army it that they're
it's it's an unprecedented moment where
they're drawing down their end strength
because they can't recruit people to the
lowest level since World War II when
they drafted people
didn't they also kick people out of the
military for not getting vaccinated they
did yeah now they're removing the
vaccine mandates in New York let's think
about this like with the two months
first of all if anyone's going to
dissuade you from joining the Army if
it's going to be either your parents
it's gonna be your mother like odds are
actually like I don't want my baby going
over there and fighting so catering to
people with two moms dude I at least one
of those moms is gonna go uh-uh you know
I'm not going in my family my dad
actually was like if you have any
creative bone in your body do not join
the military because it will break it
out of you you will you will lose it
forever because he got basically forced
to go Vietnam he was either gonna get
drafted to the Jungle so he signed up
for the Navy and went traveled the world
and then they've just you know brow
beaten told your scum clean the deck
pissant all this and uh this was my dad
that told me that but he had actual
experience really bad didn't want to be
there he didn't think the war was valid
and it wasn't even a war the military
action was valid and I want to I want to
make a point right so I want to show
this clip real quick just a little bit
not the whole thing so there she is
there you know her two moms and she said
she was raised by two moms and then I I
I take no issue with that
absolutely that's not that's how it's
about although I though a highly typical
childhood
took ballet
played violin
defending freedom from an early age just
like here's the point I want to make
Freedom what is this military yes
and you thought they would break your
creativity
they would have said hey express
yourself Ian okay I'm sorry to interrupt
this is so disturbing who is their
target market you want young men that is
my point my point is you can get no no I
I'm not concerned about targeting just
young men uh if you want to get men and
women in the Army I'm down for it
there's jobs that men and women can do
uh you want to talk about Tucker Carlson
and the pregnant flight suit thing
that's that's a little different but the
issue here is the marketing campaign
they made targets no one yep nobody no
nobody who would like yeah yeah no no no
no no it's targeting someone there this
kind of virtue signaling is extremely
over the top the the target market for
this is woke Progressive Millennials and
gen Z
but these people are not the people who
had ever want to join the Army ever yeah
so it's it's like trying it would be
like going to a fitness class expert
level uh uh um you know Tai Chi or
martial arts and trying to sell deep
fried Oreos and and double scoop you
know Banana Split Sundaes these people
are going to be like or or I'll give you
a better example going to the Olympics
during training season and being like
here's a cart full of deep fried ice
cream well they give them Gatorade which
has all sorts of food coloring in it so
they really don't care at that point
what are you doing your athletes you
can't equate Gatorade
like what's the why are you selling food
coloring to your athletes
I hear you yeah it's not great it's
similar to the fried food like deep
fried Twinkies are probably worse way
worse yeah and so the point is that the
Army made a commercial that probably
insulted their Target demographic yes
not because they're you know people who
join the Army are going to see this and
be Eli oh I'm so offended at two moms
but more so they were like do you think
this is who like this represents Us in
any way well and this goes back to the
point we made earlier right so when you
look at who is who is the Democratic
party speaking to right now in their
head but now I I would say that they
actually did have a Target Mark for this
it was exactly who they this looks like
it was for your your to your point
Millennial gen Z You Know Rich
Progressive elitist and that is who has
become in their mind the Democratic
approach for target market but that's
not really who your average Democratic
voter is I mean if I'm out in Indiana
right and I talk to a Democrat they are
much more likely to be a New York
Republican than they are a AOC Democrat
but you said something I think hits this
as well wealthy the the people who
believe these views the progressive sect
of this country are well off up you know
middle middle to upper middle class
upper class suburbanite types they're
the ones who push this do you think that
you you are going to recruit this like
24 year old Progressive woman no they're
going to be like um they this ad is so
dumb because America is totally racist I
hate you are not going to come work for
you under contract exactly you need the
people who are like America
yeah you want to Target it to kids that
are bullied and stuff like that I mean
I'm not I'm not advocating I'm not
advocating for what are you talking
about I'm not advocating for propaganda
but if the military wants to recruit
people through propaganda you want to
Target young men that feel disillusioned
and that they've been victimized no no
no no no no you don't yeah I mean that's
what I haven't done so so here's why
drafting doesn't work you can't send
people who have been drafted to go do
very serious things on your behalf
because they don't like you yeah finding
people who are bullied yeah that's
that's a terrible way to approach people
I mean is people who are looking for a
purpose and people who are driven you
want to approach them and say your
mission awaits there are people who need
you yeah there was a bad guy kind of I
think that's part of that no that's what
Putin's doing with this military that's
why they've seen an uptick is because
he's got the ability to Lead With a
Purpose versus the the propaganda well
yeah because Putin's able to tell us
people if we don't win this war
McDonald's will not come back like well
we better go fight whatever you say boss
yeah like imagine I I kind of feel like
this is what the American marketing
department thinks they're like like
Millennials like Disney
let's make an ad to recruit them like a
Disney movie it's like no you don't
understand Millennials liking Disney
means they're not gonna join right it's
the craziest thing there are these
videos
um meant uh there's a I don't know what
the right word is for it but there's a
if you go to like the cringe Topia on
Reddit there are people who who make
these Tick Tock videos where they talk
in these really weird ways where they
like Bounce Around they're acting like
Disney animation characters like when
you're watching like a new Pixar movie
or whatever they talk like this and
they're like flailing about for some
reason yeah and so you go you'll see
that
this is they're they're they think is
that what we want in the Army I I only
got to say this is going to give away
their possession like that's not what I
mean I just mean like there are people
who have become sort of uh media mutated
in their minds their perception of
reality yes it's not an issue of what
Russia is doing it's an issue of what
the US is the the kids who are growing
up here have dejected and twisted views
of reality and they behave in very
strange and broken ways it's it's just
it's disparate a cultural nonsense and
the reason why I think we're facing this
recruiting problem is because no one
believes in this country as evidenced by
our own politicians by the corporations
by woke activism in general when when
when you see someone like David Hogg
come out this guy is famous for gun
control tweeting about why parents
should be allowed to have secret sexual
conversations with five-year-olds I'm
like I kind of think you don't actually
know what you're talking about or care
and you're just saying whatever you
think the mob wants you to say which is
the most charitable response to someone
who's advocating for that right right
absolutely I mean honestly I think not
him but a lot of these people actually
are just Pito Pito adjacent groomers or
otherwise but my point is I don't want
to go off on I don't want to derail that
far my point is
the United States has no cohesive
message
we don't tell our children this is our
mission so when they grow up they all
are just hey man it doesn't matter what
happens to this country I'll extract
from it whatever I can the message used
to be free to American freedom and then
George Bush invaded the Middle East and
kept telling us because they hate our
freedom we got to keep killing people
and it just bastardized and twisted the
definition of the word freedom and now
no one understands what freedom is
anymore people are confused it's true
Ian and it's funny because the left sort
of saw that early on and they would
scoff at anyone who used the term
freedom in a positive way because of
that and they would go oh you're talking
about fighting for our freedom and they
thought it was the cringiest dumbest
thing ever but now they'll go we need to
protect our democracy against Russia
this is your democracy is the new exact
same thing
yeah it's a republic yeah but but that's
the thing they don't even use democracy
in that the phrasing of the way we look
at it democracy they use it as almost a
replacement for Freedom it just means
good democracy equals good democracy yes
I think with respect to recruitment I
mean I have friends who are combat
veterans and I remember having
conversations with them after
Afghanistan fell and I mentioned this
before but to us that was a news story
to them
they have friends who died there they'd
been shot at they'd really gone through
some horrific significant trauma and
then they just saw it all undone on live
television in front of them imagine how
horrible it is why would someone want to
enlist in this military at this point in
time given all of that there used to be
a time in this country when the
higher-ups in our government who would
send young men to fight in Wars
respected them and then we got into a
period where they more or less were
different to them and now we're at a
point in time where the people who send
these young men to fighting Wars are
expected of fighting Wars actively hate
them and everything they stand for in
everything they believe in and they're
not idiots they know that who who's
gonna fight a war for Joe Biden and
until he's gonna fight a war for Nancy
Pelosi not only do the young people not
want to fight my dad literally had to
was involved in the Vietnam conflict and
told me to my face do not join the
military yeah but that was he drafted or
did he enlist he was able to avoid the
draft because he enlisted ahead of time
they were calling the numbers he's like
I'm not going to the Jungle no way I'm
I'm joining the I'm joining the Navy so
he enlisted an effort to try listed in
the Navy it's like get a specific Mo or
something to get just to not get drafted
into the into the jungle like his cousin
got shot down on a helicopter and died
yeah oh I'm sorry I mean we were
horrific so it wasn't only that I saw
how dumb it was and shows it was my
father actively told me not to do it so
you not only do people not believe in it
their parents are telling them don't do
it yeah my so my dad was in high school
I just think just to to add to this and
this is so foreign to us but he told me
that like every single morning on the
announcements they would listen to the
radio to know which students or teachers
got drafted and one of his teachers who
was young and had just started teaching
there ended up getting drafted into the
war and I'm pretty sure he died dude you
guys study like tunnel rats they would
send these little guys down underground
to crawl through these tunnels like
sometimes they would cave in and they'd
suffocate sometimes there'd be a guy
three feet in front of him in the dark
with a gun pointed at their face then
they'd have to go set bombs under in
these tunnels all the Vietnamese this is
like this is the war you want to avoid
this is like
and think back to like 20 years earlier
you had the World War II veterans right
and I remember back when I was in school
like you'd go to the AmVets and you'd
see that that you know the group of the
remaining World War II vets and that was
the people that they'd have come talk to
the school up in Northern New York and
like you'd see like them talk about
defending American Freedom helping
defend interests over abroad and like
fighting back the Nazis and that was
something you could get on board with I
think like your average person's like
yeah like Nazis not to equal bad whereas
you look to Vietnam it's like we're
gonna go to a jungle for 20 years and do
what this child for 20 years this Civil
War that's coming is going to be
fascists versus pedos the left is gonna
scream everybody they're gonna tell
everyone the fascist must be stopped and
everyone the right is going to be like
the pedos must be stopped
those are those are the you know have
you guys seen uh operation okay groomer
that's been going around no no so
trending though yeah yeah because
basically the meme is anybody supporting
the protests you know they don't say gay
protest stuff they're groomers so they
say Okay groomer and it's really
triggering a lot of these people on the
left but I bring this up not to derail
the conversation in this direction but
to point out
there used to be an American message the
uh you know the Red Scare the Soviets
the expansion
so everyone in America was kind of
Unified
you could you could you could get people
to enlist who believe in it and you
could draft people as much as many
people didn't want to be drafted
nowadays the US is split not just in two
there's disparate factions all over the
place I mean progressives wouldn't fight
for Democrats but they'll take what they
can get in terms of politics like if an
actual fight broke out anti-fund
Democrats would not be getting along
so when it comes to going to someone and
saying what's your purpose and what's
your mission you know people in the US
are not going to say I oppose Russia
they're going to say the critical race
Theory die cult left is destroying the
planet
that's internal yeah the left is going
to say the fascists they support Putin
internal
that's true no that I mean that's a very
good point we talked about this before I
think it was actually a conversation
with Jack besobic uh and it might have
been a point Ian brought up but
basically how we live in a system where
because power changes hands so often you
can't really achieve anything but
historically that wasn't really the case
because even though the two parties had
different ideas they were similar enough
that we could work towards a common goal
though we might have different
approaches or have a slightly different
Vision it was still possible to like
continue along a specific path for a set
amount of time even with a change in
leadership but now it's like a complete
regime change in some sense when a new
person gets elected at least with
respect to the lip surf as they pay the
public and what they tell people we want
to do so yeah you're right if you ask
most people what the most serious threat
is
the right is going to point to the left
and the left's going to point to the
right who cares about foreign
adversaries at this point though you
might if you're paying attention well
there will be some conversation the
right will say China the left will say
Russia but for the most part I'd be
willing to bet if you went to someone
unprompted like a political leftist and
you'd say what is the what is the
existential threat this country faces
today they're going to say the rise of
fascism you ask someone on the right
they're going to say the critical race
theorist the cult the right may also
actually say China to be honest which is
fascist that's where it starts to to
contact what is it it's something else
it's yeah CCP is the fascist country on
earth I mean maybe the United States but
the CCP is pretty all the businesses run
through that government it's excessively
just to do internet you have to go
through China Telecom yeah I don't think
the United States is fascist it's got
elements of what the Federal Reserve
yeah but bro fascism was something
specific that's why I I just I grow
tired of using these words even the
communism it's become serious those are
100 years 100 year old terms for
specific things and ideologies that
existed during the you know
post-industrial Revolution we're dealing
with something unique and and worse in a
lot of ways yeah it's it's it's it's
it's
it's
the Matrix there's got to be a different
word for it so yeah I still I understand
it doesn't apply perfectly in all
instances I still tend to use the word
communism just because this sort of you
know
egalitarian dialectical materialism
undergird and communism is what
undergirds this stuff but fascism is is
trickier because
most people who are called fascists
don't identify as fast yeah the words
are still people on the world stage who
will identify as Communists so like the
CCP call themselves communist I mean who
calls themselves you know it is socially
acceptable among the left to throw up
the red salute yeah it it that's just
insane to me it's it's mind-blowingly
insane to me I view the red salute and
the Roman salute similarly yeah I mean
truth be told Soviets killed uh
Communists I should say Soviets but
killed way more people but they're both
psychotic ideologies
like canonized on the constant from
leftist he was homophobic right he was
super anti-gay and all that stuff like
murder gay people in Cuba yeah
he was a racist guy yeah yeah very very
racist guy that seems like problematic
isn't that the word like we we know that
the left doesn't care at all about human
life but if we can convince them that
the guy's racist like it's like a worse
person yeah yeah I mean truth be told if
you were lucky killed people they'd be
like everybody kills people food war
that happens but he killed gay people
and they're like hold on oh five
inconvenient truths about Che Guevara
from Fox News well how's this
inconvenient he was a murderous dick I
know I was just gonna say that dude even
Fox News going oh how inconvenient that
Che Guevara did it's like it's not like
he's George Washington you're going
that's unfortunate five sad truth about
Washington in 1962 Guevara said he
killed people without regard to guilt or
innocence this guy's crazy psycho but he
was beautiful so they loved him he's
cute
by the way things look have you seen the
thing right recently they're standing
young young Stalin there's look up young
Stalin so I'm pretty sure that picture
of young Stalin I've seen this and I'm
pretty sure it's not actually him I need
to double check before I understand it
was like I think it's debunked and it
was uh because that's propaganda to make
him look like he looked better that's
been blowing up all over social media I
saw on Twitter and have like thousands
let's do operation photoshopped fat
Stalin and just make like a really
unattractive we gotta do that with Putin
you want to win the war
Stalin where he was like waving at that
water body of water and they erased the
guy yeah just take that picture just
makes it no no you need young Stalin to
be a loser
so that they stopped posting this young
Joseph Stalin he looks like uh was it
gavrilo princess the guy that started
World War one that murdered that uh he
looks like that guy he reminded me of um
the hell's the guy from uh The Young
Turks thank you
yeah Hassan the fake Young Turks not the
real ones not the murderers
yeah I get confused
the ones who are inspired by those who
committed genocide not the ones who
actually did it yes thank you the ones
who initially denied the genocide not
the perpetrators of it or the ones who
have been repeatedly begged to change
their name to stop using the name of a
group that carried out a genocide and
whoever fused yeah the Armenian genocide
could you imagine if someone started a
news organization called the Hitler
right also and also like the head of
that Organization for a very long time
like actively denied the Holocaust but
then later apologize but then later
apologized but still continued to call
his organization the Hitler Youth I feel
like are you really sorry let's uh let's
do a semi-hard segue into the story
about Maxine Waters because it's it's
sad funny it's sad funny Brett Maxine
Waters warns reporter over La homeless
story you'll hurt yourself but the real
the real bit here is that she told
homeless people to go home so let me let
me get there they say Maxine Waters
tried to stop the publication of a news
story about the L about Los Angeles
homeless crisis this week reportedly
telling an LA Tri L.A Los Angeles Times
scribe you'll hurt yourself and the
community trying to put this together
investigative reporter Connor sheets
detailed a March 25th incident in South
La where hundreds of homeless people
tried to obtain Section 8 housing
vouchers after being misled by social
media rumors the would-be applicants
crashed an event held by non-profit
advocacy group fathers and mothers who
care which had been meant to help the
unhoused obtained emergency shelter at
one point Waters told the crowd I want
everybody to go home triggering an angry
response we don't got no home that's why
we're here one member of the crowd
yelled back according to the LA Times
what home we gonna go to
this is insane La is is the nightmare
dystopia we read about as kids that we
were warned about the politicians
yelling at homeless people to go home
the homeless people just everywhere Skid
Row expanding drugs and feces all over
the place
California Is A Wasteland tomorrow
snopes is going to be like well
technically she didn't say which home
they should go to so the underpass does
count exactly yeah she met their tent
she will she she could have been
referring to someone else's house here's
what I love I love it when these
leftists post photos from like the
mountains of California and they'll and
they'll say things like those
conservatives you know smack talk in
California this is what it's really like
if you got money right exactly it's like
you go to the Palisades and you're
looking at the PCH the Pacific Coast
Highway and you're like look how
beautiful this place is sure just like
an Elysium the French speaking people in
their space station I'm sure they're
looking around being like what's wrong
with with our with our country
everything's beautiful here where rich
people live it's like being a
multi-millionaire receiving experimental
treatment for your disease and being
like people claim that our Health Care
system isn't good check this out yeah
it's it's just imagine it's it's the
Hunger Games man the people in the
capital are drinking it back to vomit to
keep eating and they're like what's
wrong everything's great life is good
huh it's like yo uh people are like
living in their own ways taking dumps in
the street I guess like a nice piece of
news out of this is Michael
schellenberger who's been on the show
before is running for governor
California governor and he's focused
heavily on the on the homeless
population yeah but you know look as
much as I can appreciate it if somebody
wanted to become mayor of a garbage dump
I'm gonna be like bro good luck I guess
yeah because Rogan he was on Rogan a
couple days ago and he said Rogue was
like what just focus on La first and
he's like La is like
what if he went on Rogan and he was like
well actually my job my plan is to
segment LA and San Francisco and push
them into the Pacific and then instantly
the collective uh poverty and problems
and and everything that's wrong the
corruption uh will drop dramatically in
in California so you know just it's like
a blood transfusion well no it's like
you know it's like but with people
instead of mopping off the malignancy
yeah yeah exactly
I also it's so rich too because it's the
people from California who have these
really big great creative ideas about
how we can fix the rest of the country
even though nowhere is really quite as
bad as California I think it's too big
and well it's it's also funny because
they're they're constantly complaining
about Florida they're constantly
complaining about what goes on in
Florida while they're Con well their
state is falling apart it's like well I
don't know DeSantis has not indicated
any ambition to try to change how things
are done in California I'm pretty sure
he's just going to let that dumpster
fire burn we we joke about California
kicking off La but what if Rhonda Santos
was like we're going to separate Florida
from the rest of this country you know
only by only by a few hundred feet so
that Florida is Sovereign and protected
and we don't got to worry about a moat
around right
hungry alligators electric eels and he
can sell it it's like an alligator like
Sanctuary project
please don't feed the alligators don't
do it yeah
um please don't feed the alligators and
then you gotta have a wall with a moat
with another wall with another moat with
another wall so if you go off the wall
you just fall into the mode so this is
what's funny because they actually
claimed Trump proposed a a moat with
full of alligators which he clearly
didn't do it's just the funniest I just
you know always but you know what's an
even dumber border security idea telling
them all that they can get free
healthcare if they come here and like
having our politicians
Waters a bunch of homeless people were
told you could show up and then Maxine
Waters just yells at him tells him to go
home so just dis I mean she's so dis uh
I don't know connected I guess from
Humanity she yelled at him she said
excuse me there's nobody in Washington
who works for their people any effing
harder than I do I don't want to hear
this no no no here's the thing Maxine
Maxine when you're surrounded by
homeless people and you yelled them to
go home and then when they get mad you
say hey hey nobody fights harder than me
it's like she's like do you know how
hard I have it yeah right that's not
what my life is
uh I was just seeing did you guys see
the uh California or it's going to start
paying everyone 400 bucks rebate tax
well it's about tax plan they're
thinking about it I mean talk about it
just this is another throwing money it's
about time California Spencer I'm so
concerned for that state I do think it's
too big and like the Northern California
is way different it's like redwoods and
tree well maybe not I think there are
the redwoods in NorCal I haven't been up
that far in California but it's like
Lush uh down south it's a desert it's
they're two completely different
environments that's true it might be
worse say the Jefferson or whatever you
know it's a proposal yeah New York State
all these bigger states with the the
majority blue they're looking to do that
let's let's put all cities in bubbles
and their jurisdiction extends within
their city and nothing else
if we you know what's really funny
economic Forum yeah we should we should
just uh we should we should abolish
States and go County only
yeah so our all everything should be
done by County because then you'd see
how quickly the uh the progressive
agenda evaporates they they have uh
highly dense populations of people who
are stacked on top of each other in in
concrete jungles that smell like sour
milk and they all share this you know
similar ideology
and then you look at rural areas and its
disparate ideologies differing views in
different areas because people are more
spread out yeah in the city you smell
fumes carbon monoxide and stuff you're
constantly breathing it in so no wonder
they want to gas a carbon tax and reduce
emissions well and I mean breathing in
those toxins it leads to really good
ideas it leaves you having really good
ideas this is the problem with in my
opinion the majority of Democrats when I
come out to the middle of nowhere and I
see like a pig farmer he's like look you
know I I I don't care what you do in the
cities you know whatever I raise pigs my
pigs stink don't come out here if you
don't like the pig stink and I'm like I
get it I won't the city people do two
things they say we live in a city people
shouldn't be allowed to make things
smell like Pig so we're gonna ban Pig
farming in Utah and you're like wait
wait hold on that doesn't affect you
anymore you don't live there and they're
like well I don't want someone raising
pigs near me it's like bro no one's
raising pigs in New York well we're
gonna ban raising pigs anyway for the
whole nation that's what they're doing
with guns it's like yo uh Ricky John and
and Uncle Billy up in the mountains of
West Virginia need guns because there's
Predators there's Bears there's Banditos
and you're like I'm in New York I have
police fan guns for everyone they they
look at these problems and think the
solution is Nationwide for everybody
because they assume everywhere in the
country must be a dense Urban population
well then and then the process of
creating their solution they end up
inevitably causing more problems down
the road so they ban pigs right and then
like five years later they're like yeah
why is pork and ham and bacon
everything's so expensive so then then
they pass the pork subsidy and start
giving out checks to people to be able
to buy pork not understanding they
caused the problem they gotta ship all
the pigs to China first so we can get
our pork from China so we have to smell
it over here they're like they're like
first of all it is an ethical abuse to
kill pigs we will only eat pigs killed
on shiny soil and then they send the
pigs over there now my soul is clean to
make this real this is literally the
conversation that is exactly happening
with the the gas yeah exactly this is
literally what's happening we have have
been told that we can't have an American
oil supply because it's going to kill
the environment in return we need to
release the million barrels from our
strategic oil reserve and also we're
going to keep on buying foreign oil from
we talk about Venezuela yeah a country
that hates us and is a socialist
dictatorship well but empowering
Venezuela is a good thing that's a good
thing it's brilliant today the um there
was a really good Babylon B headline
Biden plans to sell Alaska to Russia so
we can drill for oil there oh my God
that hurts well this is the current
state of America but I I do have
confidence you know that uh
freedom is winning yeah human Ingenuity
is is amazing dude it's amazing for
hundreds of thousands of years I mean
that we only have recorded history for
like ten thousand eight thousand years
but man amazingly oh how they overcome
but I mean you do see Empires overturned
and conquered and they don't really talk
about the death that comes along with
that because it's all those people died
they didn't get to write the history
books like it's not a popular thing to
to remind people about but that's the
part of this that I don't I don't want
to see you know I mean that's how Biden
keeps on going back to this too like
well when we write the history books how
do you want to be a member and like that
seems to be a recurring yes argument
have you noticed that and that's all the
time yeah but it's very hegelian yeah
it's going to be really funny when in 50
years there's going to be a teacher
talking to the kids and in their digital
like you know hologram class and they're
going to be like who can tell me about
the leaders of the 21st century me they
were vapid self-interested egotists who
were desperate to be acknowledged by us
in the future that's correct and what do
we say to that those people suck yeah
dude that's so true there's such pick
means they're like come on future people
tell me I was great you tell me I was
good yeah that's really what it is
that's amazing I think oh what are you
saying Biden like grabbed the wheel of
the car because he I think he was like I
gotta do this for my own posterity and
then all he's doing is ruining his own
posterity by being
um you know unqualified essentially to
run the country at the moment you know
what it is look I look at Japan when uh
the the Fukushima Fukushima reactors you
know melted down or whatever the
disaster a bunch of old Japanese a bunch
of Japanese seniors were like I've lived
my life I'm gonna sacrifice myself to
save the Next Generation and these
elderly people were volunteering to go
into the reactors to try and get out of
control and many of them died I actually
uh the the fixer that guided me and Lou
gradkowski into Fukushima she was a bit
older and she was bringing journalists
and people in there to so that people
could find out what's going on she died
of cancer wow so these are the older
people being like no no it's fine like
she wasn't even that old you know but
these are people who are like I've lived
a long life I'm gonna do what I can now
because if I die the younger generation
will survive they used to have I look at
I look at what's going out in in the
United States and in Europe and it's the
opposite exactly it's old people being
like children should be should be
restricted and put in plastic boxes so
that I'm not inconvenienced it used to
be vexed if they're under the age of
five like your grandma's safe there's a
kingdom of heaven like it used to be
that you believed that if you died doing
something righteous that you'd be
rewarded and they told us that because
they probably wanted people to live like
that because it benefits Society if the
old people will sacrifice themselves to
the young people uh it's very natural no
I think it was an emergent phenomenon I
don't think that there's people who
believe that religion was like powerful
leaders who were like I must trick the
people into believing as Heaven no I
think people genuinely believed that
like yeah because you get the DMT Rush
at the end of life
at the end of the tunnel but look it's
actually really simple outside of any
theological argument or anything like
that if you take two groups of people
One Believes In being righteous and
honorable and the other doesn't which
one is more likely to survive point
astrophy because the in the in Japan I
don't know that they're necessarily
Christian were they did they do this
there's some sort of Honor Code
apparently it's a very honorific culture
well that's yeah yeah I mean they used
to they used to commit suicide like I'm
not going to pretend to be a historian
Japan but you know people understand the
memes about seppuku and uh the idea was
if if you failed or if you were
dishonorable or something you'd take
your own life now I think that's kind of
horrifying but imagine what happens then
if you have a group of Scoundrels who
are out for each other and are warring
with each other and you have a group of
people who are like I'm gonna sacrifice
myself for the greater good which one
survives in the long term well this goes
back to the point we brought up earlier
about education that's why there's such
an intense approach right now on the
left to control what is and is not
taught in government schools and it's
because you see the kids who are raised
by their parents who have more of the
religious backings they're getting
taught this at home the the idea that
there is something Beyond you in this
present there is a future that you're
building for that you're not even going
to see one day whereas if the left can
take that and get rid of that in the
government schools at a young age then
they're basically undoing the work that
the parents have invested and it's it's
setting up to to your point the the
world view that goes into that instant
gratification without thinking of the
posterity what comes next they're
they're I feel like the Democrat side
it's obviously not literally every
person but it's the overwhelming
majority are the people who are like I
hope future people like me that's why
they always say you're on the wrong side
of History it's like I'm not motivated
by what future people think you know
imagine being someone in in China in the
early 1900s yeah you were on the wrong
side of History opposing the the
murderous regime of of Mao and the Gang
of four or whatever but uh uh today
you're now on the right side of history
at least to us I'm sure in communist
China they still don't like those who
you know resisted they don't like the
government of Taiwan the actual
government of China but that's the point
I don't care what you think the right
side of history is yeah if these if
these you know
Die cultists end up taking over and it
gets bad to the point where horrific
things are happening in this country and
I end up leaving
I'm not going to be going around being
like I guess I was on the wrong side of
History I'm going to be like my country
was taken over by Psychopaths yeah
exactly like oh man I wish I would have
been on the right side of that one
because like just because you lost
doesn't mean think about it but but
listen to how realize how they think
then yeah they're a legitimate
legitimately there are Democrat
activists who thought it's not right but
it will win that's why they decided to
opt to supporting dicultism well I just
want to say if I were teleporter to the
Future and everyone was transgender and
it was a communist country where
children didn't pick their identity
until they were 12 years old I would
just make fun of them I would hope they
didn't like me I would hope they didn't
consider me um and say we got to fight
for what we believe in yeah but I guess
my point is there's actually an
arrogance to saying I want to be on the
right side of his of History not just in
the sense that you are presuming that
you would be for doing what you're
aiming to do but also you're judging all
of the past and saying well if we as
modern people liked what you'd did then
you were one of the good guys so my
aspiration should be to have future
people well who says moral erosion
doesn't occur in some areas there are
things we look back on as being horrible
that we're actually better and there are
things that we look on today as being
wonderful that are actually horrible
imagine siding with some politics just
because you think it's the one that's
going to win yeah like I'd rather be
correct imagine could you imagine being
someone who like made very popular
YouTube videos and like song parodies
and then end up taking them down because
you were scared that you know the left
would you get banned or they would they
would come after you and that you you
genuinely just thought it's not worth
fighting for these things I think are
true because I'll lose imagine being
that kind of person people are scared
too I mean I I went up so as you
mentioned earlier in my day job I'm a
sales executive and I do a lot of
talking about business technology cyber
security and I went to Wisconsin I was
talking at a small business owners
conference and um we were just talking
about cyber security stuff at the very
end of the Q a this guy comes up and
he's standing there and uh he goes Brian
you're you're very political and yet you
also do a lot in the private sector how
do you bridge the Two Worlds and it kind
of caught me off guards in there for a
conversation about cyber security and I
was like honestly like at the end of the
day you just you just got to be your
authentic self and like say this is who
I am this is who I believe and I just I
firmly believe that good people will
find good people and that good people
will bring out the good in people so
instead of hiding what you believe and
and keeping that back I think we should
lead with our values lead with our our
ideas and and focus on building things
that are outside of the the traditional
mainstream getting away from the
explaining right yeah good ideas don't
require Force that's right um available
at Brian eagleshow.com forward slash
shop and if you wanted to create a
better future the opportunity is there
right now you can start to build these
Solutions I mean I had a guy in my show
he's the CEO of a pediatric cancer
research company and they have not only
created a system to get donations
through cryptocurrency but now now
they're using blockchain technology to
help increase the research efficiencies
of you name the the focus and he's
talking about how their Chicago schools
that are they do research and how they
were getting siled into you know I'm
focusing on this project I'm focusing on
this project and they're mile apart from
each other they're doing the same
project they had no idea this entire
time so taking it out of these silos
putting it onto blockchain and now
creating an open environment where we
can get things Advanced faster research
done more quick and and we're seeing
more people's lives being saved as a
result of that and that's all because
somebody decided I'm going to go by my
values I think that blockchain and nfts
has a amazing opportunity to just change
the game and they they jumped on that
and now they're actually making things
better they're saving little kids lives
that's a big deal I figured it out
the right the Libertarians whatever need
to make the metaverse first yes that's
what we're working on I just saw a
little prototype on Wednesday they want
us to ghettoize ourselves no no it's
just same with what is doing with neural
now when they so they control all the
big Tech spaces conservatives have
seated control I'm kidding by the way
about this yeah but my point is
the the right the Libertarians have
seated control of of our current
economic system
internet and social media to leftists
and Silicon Valley
so whether it's metaverse or whatever my
point is the right needs to start
getting active and paying attention to
what's going on web3 yeah and Building
Things now I'm glad that elon's doing
the neural net we talk about it and
everyone's like I don't know if I'm
gonna but it's good that it's him
because that dude open sources Tesla
patents yeah if we can see it says all
your patents are belong to us if you
look it up online I don't know if it's
every Tesla Pad but it's a bunch so
someone like that build the metaverse
free the software code or that's what
I'm looking for that's why we're working
on the metaverse with our current
project with uh this charity that we're
starting okay
but we need to do that before I was just
like let's just let it happen let's beg
the authorities to make them open source
their code that's not I'm not an
authoritarian I'm not a I'm not a
fascist we got to do it ourselves so
let's do a tough call who wants to go in
the metaverse I don't I do but if you
build it first you can prevent these
these wackos from doing all the evil
things they plan on doing we're just
basically or because they could make
their own couldn't they they could but
you can now is that the standard of what
is acceptable and what people I mean
think about it we we look and judge for
the most part streaming platforms based
on what Netflix was right and that's
what the subscription model turned into
but the interface not the ethics correct
correct 100 correct so like we can do
that though in terms of setting the the
groundwork almost again setting that
narrative and then either somebody else
on the left would have to build
something better that's going to attract
more people or they have to react and
and change Behavior
so I think we can we can almost do both
if that makes sense no I'm not sure you
think that we can build uh comparable
technology and then change the behavior
of what they use because once you
control the tech you can decide how the
universal user interface looks and
slightly guide people's behaviors I hear
what your question is it ethical or not
but yeah that's what you can do well and
the left is doing it right now yes and
that's Mark Zuckerberg is overtly doing
it yes yep 100 well and that's the thing
right with these social media platforms
people are already living online it's a
very disturbing thing it's like we're in
The Matrix but we're profoundly disabled
because our only interface is this this
screen in our fingers to type with and
if people do end up integrating with the
metaverse they're going to look back on
us and go how sad and insane uh Ian you
your analogy was it'll be like Morse
code to them they just won't even
understand how we could have such a
longer interface but I still think it's
sad I think we should try to spend as
much time in the real world as possible
I agree but um if
metaverse in any fashion be it Nora link
or just VR headsets becomes just
dominant in economics why remote work
for instance makes it a viable option
and the right just says no no people
should spend time in reality well that's
not how people are actually going to
respond that's not you know obviously
you might want it to happen but doesn't
mean it's going to happen that's also
because so what you can do is you can
make a preemptive technological strike
and then when people do typically adopt
this tech for say remote working you own
the means you can actually say only two
hours a day so then the conversation
isn't whether or not Elon Musk is going
to build something else or by Twitter it
will be there already basically mine's
software code is available to take and
build on right now if Elon wants to do
it what's easier to storm the walls of
Rome or to go there before Rome was
built plant your flag and then say we're
you know this is our land yeah it's
easier before you know so it's easier to
claim the territory before the before
you know someone else builds up their
fortifications and things like that so
argue your point about rather spending
time in reality what the argument you're
going to get back with that that is the
the metaverse is reality it's just a
different way of seeing reality it's
another kind like TV shows are real
they're just not I know what you call
this base reality I don't know how to
how to reference this is real well it's
all real it's just it's their dramatized
reality yeah so so when you're looking
at an event that happened in the real
world there's a reason we create this
distinction about whether something is
based on true events when we're watching
something in media even though that term
is also very much abused it's because
there is a significant difference
between something actually occurring in
the world and a story that someone has
told playing out before you in a
simulated manner you need to watch these
videos from tick tockers who are they
they do these really we mentioned
earlier in the show where they like if
you watch a Pixar movie people don't
just talk they bounce when they talk so
Ian you have to understand and that's
what they do on Tick Tock they do this
weird like and they do side talking on
their mouths and they like eye twitch
metaverse will amplify that 1000 fold
because these people are putting on a
performance in their phones they
probably don't go and actually do that
direct to like regular people at the gas
station in the metaverse they'll be
doing it 24 7. that's a great Point
they'll be raised from five years old
around people doing that and they'll
come out and here's what you need to
understand
when we watch these cringe Tick Tock
videos we understand what they're doing
you know smart sane people say yes
you're emulating a a an animation
character from like frozen or something
but what we don't understand is when the
metaverse drives this to you know a
thousand fold and this becomes normal no
no it's not going to be people bouncing
around
there's a connection between base
reality and movie characters bouncing
and then humans adopting it but what
happens when there's a rapid expansion
of this bizarre behavior you'll you'll
you'll have people just going like
twitching and and shaking and uh people
and how about this one young girls on
Instagram were getting fake Tourette's
yep there was a viral story yes
because they were seeing it and and
what's going to happen is I have a
friend in Psychology who's explaining
this to me imagine imagine this right
now we know what tourettes is let's say
in the metaverse a world develops one
block at a time that results in people
who have this weird tick where they just
start like screaming screeching
so what I mean yeah the easiest way to
explain it I suppose is the Tai Chi
Hitler video I bring up all the time
where these these companies were trying
to make algorithmically manipulative
videos that YouTube would promote them
to babies you end up with the Incredible
Hulk and Adolf Hitler doing Tai Chi
while they sing nursery rhymes
to us to a regular human you're like
what what is this this is psychotic the
algorithm put these pieces together to
manipulate the code now if you live in
the metaverse and you're exposed to that
a thousand fold you're eventually going
to walk out going
and they're going to be like what is
this guy doing and they're gonna be like
it's just a thing they do in these shows
in the metaverse regular people in the
real world are going to be like yo
what's wrong with what's wrong with
these people already we watch these tick
tockers bounce around like they're in a
Disney you know cartoon where like
something's wrong with these people
imagine if it's cranked up a
hundred-fold and they're just going
I mean we can't communicate with each
other as it is just imagine what it's
going to be like in 20 years yeah when
you look at ROBLOX what's happening is
the kids that are in Roblox in the in
the metaverse with that system are also
building it as they're in it so you'll
see uh uh basically a rapid expansion or
um compounding expansion of change right
in those systems so if the the people
with fake Tourette's are actually the
ones that are also building reality as
they're then they'll create like a
Tourette's ridden reality that makes you
get more Tourette's and then it could
exactly like a feedback systems you know
people are gonna people will rapidly
start speaking very differently if you
if if the meta if metaverse becomes
something more prominent people will
build pocket communities very much like
a Discord or whatever but if you can
experience it via neural link man then
people are going to stay in those
communities they're going to isolate and
it's going to be like after the fall of
Rome uh the the Latin language splits up
and becomes the romance language is a
bunch of different ways and now you
can't even communicate between them to a
certain degree you know what else
happened in Rome is they split the
Empire in half because they couldn't
control it's just basically like the
metaverse and base reality if we split
like that and you have the Eastern Roman
Empire and the Western Roman Empire
which is now the world and the metaverse
or the universe and the metaverse check
it out already because of the internet
we're speaking two different languages
when we say racism we're talking about
Prejudice based on race the left is
talking about systems of pressure you
know Prejudice or whatever from the
dominant groups it means something
totally different to them yeah amplify
that these communities isolate further
they go into private servers they go
into metaverse you will create two
distinct languages over time maybe even
more yeah probably it's how you end up
with you know again you know Rome and
then when it falls you have the romance
languages they're all very similar but
very different because they all end up
getting isolated from each other yeah
and to sort of tie it into the
interesting philosophical question you
posed earlier which is why and how do we
differentiate between reality and
narrative and what goes on in the
metaverse
it's important to remember that the
strongest teacher for humans generally
speaking is experience and so if someone
experiences something or believes
they've experienced something it's going
to influence the habits they end up
developing and we see this even with
film and television when you're sitting
in front of a TV set I mean it's obvious
that you're not in it you're looking at
a screen in front of your face you're
watching the main character it's not
being seen from your point of view but
we live in a country where basically
everyone has main character syndrome
right now and they think their life is
some kind of strange soap opera where
they're the main character and so people
have begun to interact with the real
world in these bizarre and disordered
ways just because of how much attention
we place on fiction uh relative to what
we should place on it which is
significantly less and
um if we get the metaverse up and
running it's just going to be that
multiplies to degrees like I couldn't
even predict right I agree it's the
craziest thing to me how many
Millennials have Maine character
syndrome when I'm obviously the main
yeah exactly how could they not realize
that there's uh there's well and to be
fair it certainly didn't originate with
Millennials I mean solipsism is
basically just the pretentious
philosophical way of saying you have
main character Central but even that's a
little different though because the main
character syndrome also touches on the
way the narratives are structured and
how you place your life into that
category like you're on the hero's
journey could you guys imagine if
Sheamus was the main character and I I
am thank you but it's all in Freedom's
World exactly little do you all know we
we are actually just a show in the
freedom Tunes world so they watch us we
get a glimpse into them only something
why is this so funny to you guys
Seamus's brain he's like of course you
are exactly come on freedom tunes that
would be sad here's the thing if I was
the main character that would be very
depressing I think I'm the best this
universe has not get out of here I
wouldn't want to live in that Universe
I'm flawed but like I'm the most
interesting person we can focus on well
not yet you're growing into that that's
a journey but doesn't the Show have to
start with the main character being
interesting not only you see their great
flaw which for you I'm just kidding
I love I'm Irish too
Rambo do we see 20 years of Rambo's
growth no no the movie starts where it
starts he's the main character so what
you need to understand Sheamus is that
whenever the movie that you're in
finally starts probably when you're 35
you're going to be super ripped with
like your sleeves torn off at a bunch of
guns it's going to be post-apocalyptic
and you'd be like the name's Sheamus and
I'm here to save you all and then they
find out like you're also Catholic and
they're like and you believe in God and
then you can it'll be like deliver the
wisdom of the ages and it'll be a good
story I mean to get really deep here but
what is at its fundamental base the
hero's journey it's the story of the
hero being successful but overcoming
some major event and we see we see this
a lot it's gonna hit me where people
have created the trauma whether it's
real or not in their lives so they can
feel that I have overcome this terrible
thing to be my hero and and they look
for trauma they look for the bad things
in order to justify their hero's journey
amen well that's true and also another
really Insidious thing that's happened
is people expect their problems to be
solved much more quickly than is
reasonable always saying well I mean
it's instant gratification it's also the
fact that when you watch these
television shows if it's a 22 minute
long program the problem arises and it's
solved within that neat little three-act
structure people also don't understand
that change can be irreversible it took
me a while to understand this and maybe
that's just part of being young but as a
kid it just seemed to me that everything
was reversible everything could be
undone I had to learn the lesson as I
got older that that wasn't true and I
didn't watch a whole lot of Television
that could just be something that's
built into humans and we have to learn
but I suspect not I I think it's the
narratives that were felt that were fed
that program us that way didn't they
denature an egg
a protein had a chemical change an egg
was cooked I think and the proteins fold
or something like that they don't want
to misrepresent them they turn an egg
into a hard-boiled egg and they were
like the general idea is you know you
can't reverse this process chemical
reaction yeah and then they figured out
way to actually reverse the process so
like you could undo Burns maybe
theoretically with this kind of
Technology it's pretty cool interesting
so yeah yeah but there's still a lot
that we can't undo but let's say you're
in the metaverse and you have a save
point yeah or a a Time stone or
something but this has happened to me
right like I spend almost all of the
time that I'm doing anything artistic
doing it on the computer with my drawing
tablet dude I have been drawing with a
pencil and paper and have literally
thought I have to like I have to hit the
undo button and then realized oh my gosh
I'm not using a computer you know I I
just admit it how amazing would it be if
you were like a business meeting and you
accidentally said like you're you're
like look when we approach this or
orgasm I mean organism oh geez all right
I'm just going to load my Save State
real quick when you were approaching
this organism and that's danger people
would do crazy stuff if you ever see
someone play Skyrim and then reload
their game after they go into the City
and just take wait wait wait wait
imagine this in the metaverse there's a
bunch of other people who are there and
some guy walks in into your office and
then you see him pull up and he goes
quick save and you're like oh
good like little short film this could
be a good little short film but
someone's in the metaverse for the first
time and they think by pressing restart
it like actually restarts it but it
actually puts everyone back into their
starting position but of course because
there are other people in the metaverse
they have the memory of what you just
did so this person keeps screwing up and
restarting and doing all these absurd
things they're like dude we didn't
forget that you did that that's what
actually here's how I'd approach it it's
uh the person who goes in the metaverse
for the first time thinking it's a
single player game and so they're going
around and they're saying really awful
things and they're like ripping their
clothes on Twitter they're tweeting
about them but they don't know because
they're in the metaverse yeah
and then you know you're in the
metaverse where you can't actually
harass people in these ways and so then
it's like you're you've been banned and
like what happened and they pull up
their their meta Twitter or whatever and
it's like everyone's posting videos of
you and it's like oh no I want to weigh
in on this main character syndrome
firstly I think everyone is the main
character you're the main character and
you're the main character it was the
main character I am and so are you it's
not logical but it is real we all have
this person maintaining our reality
um I think that a lot of stuff with
Marvel these superhero movies have put
this in people's brains with their
heroes and villains and that there's a
like you said earlier a show you know
you wrap it by the end of the show and
it starts again also I feel like Donald
Trump did a really disservice to the
species when he started talking about
winning and losing so much as a
candidate like it was never about
winning to any candidates before him
they never talked about we gotta win it
was about doing what's right for America
and he came up and it's like no matter
what we're gonna win and now you see
that all over the place people want to
win and they do dirty things to win and
it's not about that we all win if we
work together I think I think Donald
Trump's the main character he's
definitely the main character and and
and and we're all just NPCs in his story
we're in his world I mean look at it
it's true look I mean I have a little
bit of a solipsist I have a little bit
of the main character look at his story
yeah it's like you know he he's he you
start the video game off and of course
you have access to all this like wealth
and privilege and stuff you know small
loan of a million dollars all right
right so you know and then he's a you
know Playboy billionaire celebrity
philanthropist own owns a building with
his name in Gold letters then he becomes
the president
dude it's hysterical Hillary Clinton
spent her whole life doing everything
she could employing every every cynical
political move possible to become the
president this guy wakes up on board
he's like you know what I could be
president I better try to be president
and then he beats her and that's what
she hates you so much I know but it's
hysterical yeah it's hysterical I mean
you know in in all honesty though Trump
had been planning on running for a while
and I should also bought the bought the
the website in the name like years in
advance to Charlie Sheen Charlie Sheen
kind of created the winning narrative
and we're winning winning and then all
of a sudden Trump started saying it
winning I'm winning uh I blame Charlie
Sheen for all this what Charlie she's
the main character you were too crazy
there when you were talking about your
Adonis blood and stuff like that you
went too crazy it's like how many people
do you think really were taking Charlie
Sheen's life advice there probably like
16 000 probably six that's I'll be
specific that is very specific maybe Ian
is a banker it was like written into
their code
Ian's actually this is we're in the
metaverse
player I thought I was I went through a
psychosis phase in 2006 seven on YouTube
I was smoking a lot of weed making
videos and watching myself and I was
like I am this is my reality I'm
creating this as I go and things start
to synergize like when you make a lot of
YouTube videos when you're online and
you're exposing your soul to people
things do start to synergize for you
like you start to blend in with reality
becomes one thing I I had gone so far
psycho that I didn't I was unbalanced
because you are the main character but
you're also part of a system where
there's all these other main characters
that are equally as powerful as you it's
called an MMO
everybody back in the game multiplayer
online game yeah so
when you play like World of Warcraft or
whatever you can see who the NPC is you
can see who the players are so maybe
as I was saying uh last week there are
some people who don't believe they have
souls you know and they'll say things
like just a wet robot right and I'm like
man I kind of feel like I have a soul
like I've had experiences maybe the
reality is they just don't you know and
and so but but no no but you know
Sheamus you laugh but like
if it's it's I kind of was thinking like
why should I assume someone has a soul
for telling me they don't because I
think because I do because because I
think even though having a soul is a
wonderful beautiful thing and it's very
good we have them on some level when you
really consider the responsibility it's
a very frightening thing and it might be
easier to abdicate that responsibility
and say I just don't have one I don't I
don't freak out when I'm in World of
Warcraft and I'm talking to a shopkeeper
to like sell a bunch of crap and repair
my armor the consequences aren't real
though that's why yeah because you have
that you could you have that redo
exactly you don't realize shopkeeper
might be you don't have a redo button in
World of Warcraft I mean well you can't
you can turn off the game and turn it
back on no you no you can't oh no you
can't you can't yeah no it's an MMO but
if you die you just respawn yeah
uh what you so it's all in MMOs it's all
real time if you sell your gear and you
made a mistake it's gone or you can you
can do a buyback but uh when you die
your Armor gets damaged and you respawn
because the point of the game is so you
keep playing okay but uh yeah you you
die there's no reloading there's no
resetting so my point isn't so much
about about turning the game on and off
my point is in World of Warcraft as
someone who is actively playing the game
you know who the other players are you
can see them running around and doing
stuff you'll notice some of the
characters running around just don't
behave like human beings and you can't
even communicate with them effectively
and I start wondering about this they
call them NPCs for a reason if I go to
someone and say hey I I feel a soul
within me I feel some something greater
than me it guides me do you and say no I
say do you feel you have us all they say
no maybe they don't like I'll trust him
I guess
why would I assume if they're not
experiencing it they have one well if
we're talking about people in the real
world I think if you had a soul in Free
Will by definition that would give you
the option to say that you don't
think if we were all required to say we
had a soul that we did we would lose our
free will
oh I'm just saying
I think it's projection
to be like I felt something within me
and I've experienced something therefore
other people must have as well and if
they can't something must be wrong
there's something about clearing your
mind and your that allows you access to
your soul I I believe like the amyloid
plaque on the neurons in the brain
causes Alzheimer's it also diminishes
your ability to feel I I think so so
let's uh let's wrap this up real quick
sorry but wrap it up with uh just a
quick conspiracy theory oh yes what if
they say that's a fluoride what do they
say calcifies the pineal gland I heard
it turns Frog's gay too but a lot of
that's atrazine but they were
hermaphroditic so the conspiracy theory
would be what if powerful satanic or
maybe maybe it's not fair to say satanic
but like just evil we're trying to cloud
people's connections with the greater
you know whatever it may be whether
you're religious or otherwise whatever
you think that is what if there are
people who genuinely can't see into it
because they've been polluted or you
know blocked in some way I mean I think
what you're saying the idea of evil for
sure is a real thing like evil is out
there just as good but I mean like some
people have a greater connection to to
to the right the other realm or Beyond
the Veil or we want to call it and some
people don't why well because of toxic
chemicals or whatever I'm obviously
talking specifically about conspiracy
theories I'm not saying are true but you
know uh one thing we mentioned in the
show before was just like uh DMT giving
you this connection that people have
these profound experiences and DMT is
produced by your brain naturally yeah
what if that what if what if there are
people who are being inhibited from
being able to to feel the greater power
or whatever well I mean there's a really
fascinating philosophical discussion
there about just the effect that our
hormones and neurochemistry have on us
and it's been waging we all agree that
there are some people who behave more
and morally than others that much is
evident
and then the question becomes how much
of what this person did with their own
agency how much of this is a result of a
neurochemical imbalance or a mental
illness I tend to lean towards agency
because I think we over pathologize and
we sort of blame everything on the
person's environment and don't really
attribute responsibility to people
anymore which is unfortunate but it's it
is a very interesting conversation and
like on a case-by-case basis it can be
difficult
let's go to super chats if you haven't
already smash that like button subscribe
to this channel share the share with
your friends and head over to
timcast.com for our members only show
coming up at about 11 or so p.m as a
member you're going to support our work
help our journalists keep doing their
journalism on the ground reporting we're
eternally grateful for all of your uh
support in that matter but uh smash that
like button let's see what we got
all right slain hope says have we all
forgot that one of Joe Biden's first
acts as president was killing six kids
in a drone strike is that really what he
did yeah he messed up the Afghanistan at
the end there oh remember they were
trying to get the uh and they ended up
getting a guy they had water in his
trunk he was bringing water inside to
his kids and then they have drone strike
in this car wow yeah
wow I can't say I'm surprised and this
is there were so many bleeding hearts
who were going we have to get rid of
trump he's so terrible look how bad he
is look how horrible he is on issues of
human life it's like dude Joe Biden's
worse on all of those he's worse on
every single one of them and he has been
consistently because Joe Biden got
elected the U.S Senate at the age of 29.
he was 29.
man you've been there his entire life
all right Liam O'Brien says so he's done
nothing productive yeah exactly we we
love you took Ian I'm not sure maybe
maybe two we love you too Ian oh okay we
love you too go see a fellow Irishman in
the show so often thank you Tim for
opening my eyes and turning me into a
small libertarian oh okay there you go
I'm what they call a plastic Patty you
know wasn't born in Ireland other people
look I didn't I didn't come in here guns
Blaze but I'm a little Irish leprechaun
I have a possible a fan sent it because
you all make fun of me no for my name
and my ethnic identity you do no no you
guys do you're always going like I'm
Irish I'm Irish everyone's like bro
you're from Chicago every single time I
do anything wrong or I say something
offensive on the podcast and the splc or
Daily Beast write an article Tim goes
he's Irish he has he's internalized his
irishness why did Sheamus have his
offensive things well you know the
inhumanity we've seen this world he's
Irish so he feels it when people don't
know this but Sheamus is actual uh
dialogue Act is a Chicago accent
actually it is the way I really exactly
right Sheamus talks about garage doors
spent most spent the vast majority of my
life in in the suburbs out there but uh
you know I'll steal the street cred from
you Tim you know people used to actually
talk like that and then it was a cable
TV that got rid of it all yeah in every
area I mean that's basically how my
uncle's talk my parents have a little
bit when I was a little kid I had a
little bit of it uh it's yeah I was
Northeast Ohio I went out to New York to
start acting and I I actively dispersed
my my accent I guess I started to talk
like TV where there is no accent kind of
or whatever yeah I was looking at like
some of the First cartoons I ever did
when I still lived probably like 15
minutes outside Chicago and there were
just like certain words I pronounced
differently and it's fun because you
don't notice changing your pronunciation
you don't yes
yeah it's like democracy and yeah well
yeah to get the Chicago a you don't say
ah you say yeah yeah yeah it's like it's
like a yeah the Apple it also depends on
the part too because in different parts
of the city people do sound a little bit
different and it's crazy because when
you live there you don't hear it from
other people no like to you everything
just sounds normal no yeah and then
other people will be like here ye apple
and you'll be like yeah and then you'll
be like when people really accentuate it
like you're like who talks like that
the fun go down to the Apple Store the
one thing that always got me though is
that people made up that Chicagoans say
Chicago and it's like a meme but nobody
says in Chicago it's an awesome not an
ass sound I understand if it was Chicago
people would say shikiago but literally
no one does that it's the weirdest thing
when people are like oh you're from
Chicago what I'm like bro no one says
that it's funny because they say apple
that's the thing with the people with
the thickest Chicago accents say like
Chicago they actually don't it's almost
like in Chicago they say they say like
Chicago the people I know what the
thickest accident is better lives in the
city like actually pronounce the word
Chicago within the accent it's a weird
thing yeah but outside of Chicago
everyone thinks they say shikiago you
ever do that thing where you say a word
like 10 or 20 times in a row and it
starts to sound really weird sound am I
making that's called semantic satiation
let's read some more interesting it's
great Remy says Tim you should have
answered in your faucy voice it would
have been hilarious yeah come on I'll do
that next time hello the next time the
CDC card are you wearing your mask
you better be wearing two men
two men otherwise the droplets will get
all over your grandmother all right
where were we right right lines as CDC
is calling to see if you're home so they
can SWAT you later
oh my gosh yeah we got swatted again I
heard that yes part of the business I
imagine that these entertainment
Industries once it gets to a certain
size it's just like 10 a day and you
just have it go right to law enforcement
you have law enforcement on premises so
it's all handled without you having to
deal with it
it's crazy you know someone mentioned
this to me they said they asked me why
it wasn't big news I can't remember who
asked me this and I was like I was like
I'm not sure what do you mean they were
like well it's like you know you have
one of the biggest podcasts and you've
been swatted seven times in three in in
like two and a half months
wouldn't that be a big story to these
like journalists who are constantly
talking about the dangers of media like
Andy no got attacked you know it was bad
and even CNN covered it we had the bomb
squad show up here we had uh we were
swatted with the cop walking past the
camera it's happened seven times
and like
nope you know it's really weird we are
something really weird about me in this
show that like we're under the radar for
whatever reason the show's big enough
but nobody cares to talk about it I
think it's a good thing I guess but I
think it's also because you have three
channels and so I think you're someone
people will talk about but because you
do three different shows every day it's
like it's difficult to pinpoint the one
that people are gonna say you're known
for well the interesting thing is I've
noticed there are a lot of people who
don't watch don't know they all exist
like there are people who watch this
show who don't know that I have a
Morning Show yeah and that I have two
other YouTube channels over a million
subscribers so I've noticed when people
are smack talking me they'll say
something like oh yeah he does this like
you know he does these videos like this
and people be like no he does like a
podcast with people and they're like no
he doesn't what are you talking about
Mandela effects bro they're like I came
from the universe where Tim pool just
does Vlogs there's a guy came from the
universe where he does a podcast I'm
like I don't know maybe I should just
get rid of half the shows because I will
say there's a diminishing return your
shows cool though they're good to listen
to because it's pretty quick and you
give like good news talk about some
interesting stuff the interesting thing
is on weekends the clips from IRL get
way more views because people who know
who watch all the shows don't have
anything else to watch so that means the
harder I work the less money I end up
making you know so it's actually a lot
I'm trying to get you to I'm trying to
get Tim to write music with me during
the day but that would entail him like
you can't do it I worked you know work
basically like I wake up at seven teach
the humans immediately start reading the
news and then I work typically until
around three is when I finish the
morning show stuff like 3 30ish then I
exercise eat food and then we get ready
for this show
some days I get lucky enough to go to
the bank oh exciting lucky all right
honey that he loves his stacks of cash
all over his base
while playing that song celebrate pine
tree Squad says I haven't had a good
laugh during timcast IRL in a while
between the commentary on CDC calling
and all the rest of the good laughs are
doing me good stay safe everyone much
love from Pine Tree Squad nice this was
a very fun episode
we'll make sure we have the CDC call
more often yeah that was funny my phone
rang and I was just kind of like I gotta
get they keep calling me yeah and
there's it's the CDC for all I know
they're going to be like you know say
something crazy say you need to pay him
in Apple gift cards that's the way to do
it it'll be hilarious you let them know
that they're being recorded and if
they're okay with that that's the way if
you ever want to put someone on a video
that's you got to do that I think
legally you got to do that so they
wouldn't wouldn't have been funny if
like it's I answer the phone it's like
hello he says Dr Anthony fauci are you
going to say I am my car broke down and
I need you to send me a Walmart gift
card
wow that sounds true where do I send it
just uh take a picture and send it you
need to get Apple gift cards from your
local Walmart and send them to me
could you imagine if if Sheamus if
you're if you actually were you know
were able to pull that off call people
pretend to be call you know you should
do you should legit call someone with
like a different number and tell them
you're like someone you know and Tommy
Jordan Peterson
Peterson listen to me if you want to
embody the archetypal hero you need to
go to Walmart and get some iTunes gift
cards you need to send them to me you
have to scratch the label off the back
and tell me the codes immediately listen
your computer has a virus I'm trying to
fix it you owe the IRS ten thousand
dollars I'm trying to help wait wait
wait Do do Ben Shapiro calling to to
inform you about your ex your car's
extended warranty okay like I'm trying
to call you reaching your cash extended
warranty how are you doing today sir
okay did you know that you're here's the
thing I hang up on them immediately so I
don't even know what they say I know a
bunch of barrel would say like if you
cut if you want your car to last a long
time you have to buy a decent warranty
for it because these Things Fall Apart
folks you don't make things in America
anymore like we used to okay gang okay
gang
Peterson
you have to you have to get the app and
frankly if you could grab some
Applebee's gift cards as well
you have to help me stop the cultural
Marxist send me 75 iTunes gift cards
immediately can we like prank call Dave
Rubin doing that okay dude he picked up
and be like he'd be like I agree
like you have to send these Walmart gift
cards in a radical marxists are going to
take out like yo hey hey hold on we
should legit prank call somebody like
just find some prominent podcast or
numbers I have and we'll film it for the
Vlog so they'll be like who is this it's
Jordan Peterson Jordan why are you
calling me I need gift cards
listen listen Brett Weinstein your
computer has a virus I'm trying to get
it off your computer you need to let me
help you just install this program
give me your password we accidentally
put ten thousand dollars in your bank
account we need you to send it back to
us here's the screenshot
what other what other
George Peterson calling to say his car
broke down he needs you to send him
money I've just been doiling random
numbers in my phone trying to find a
good Samaritan somebody please you know
gas prices are right now they'll only
gas is getting so expensive they'll only
accept iTunes gift cards actually you
know you know it'll be good you know
we'll do like legit let's totally do
this but you can call as the
intellectual dark web and do Dave Rubin
thank you and Jordan Peterson all trying
to convince someone that they're all
there at the same time listen you
absolutely have to buy these gift cards
all right okay gang we are actually
going to starve to death out here
[Laughter]
aw awake as Dawn says Arizona governor
signed multiple bills one abortion after
15 weeks is illegal two proof of
citizenship to vote and three prevent
youth from Tran surgery and
participation of trans women in women's
sports kind of feels like uh Arizona's
gonna turn dark red in this upcoming
election what do you think it's gonna do
for Cinema
I don't know I think people actually
kind of like her the left hates her yep
you know she's she's pushed back on
Democrats a lot or enough and maybe
I don't know maybe she might have to
change to be a republican yeah
yeah yeah well I mean she's like
basically turning into uh the the
version of uh what the hell's a guy West
Virginia mansion mansion thank you Joe
manchin I was gonna say King someone
someone said call CNN please oh yeah
yeah I wonder I mean I've got a bunch of
phone numbers I have a like I got a
bunch of people we'll call them we'll do
a prank I have like a journalist from
the Atlantic oh sweet
a ton of Vice journalists I think I have
uh I've got like high up Vice people
obviously uh ABC news people what else I
got MSNBC famous comedians
let's do oh yeah they would know we were
pranking them you know but they'd
probably just laugh and go along with it
or something like yeah that's true you
should call Ryan Longford yeah
let them know they're being recorded
before you start talking in Peterson's
voice yeah I'm recording you all right
this is this is very important it's it's
I record everything I do in case I want
it to be a lecturer if I upload this to
Youtube it'll get like 800 000 views all
right people like me wrong and then he
can tell everyone on YouTube to make to
give him his uh his gift cards and
scratch the back up and be the number
Tim oh my gosh please read the it was
one right up there the the five dollar
one from this football no a little
higher
it was this it might be gone forever it
might be gone forever they said my
cartoon inspired them to change their
name whoa really where was that yeah
yeah oh man I think it's gone I think
it's gone correct that's awesome his
name was my football which is a line
from my recent video you guys need to
check it out oh yeah I don't see a video
I guess it's gone forever
I guess we lost it oh well thank you
oh no maybe you were just seeing the
these are the older super chats
so maybe it's just down it's down
further yeah no it's probably down
further but I want to thank you my
football question mark question all
right Bruce and I want to ask you guys
to watch that video so you get the joke
okay Freedom Tunes Bruce says stop
trying to take DeSantis from us in
Florida vagrants no we we all deserve
DeSantis we do hold on do you think
think we deserve the scientists I don't
think we just I think he's great I think
we want him do we deserve him I don't
know man what do you mean by that I
don't think we just I was just kidding
being like you can't have him you know
no no no no here's the thing you're not
gonna keep him you're not gonna win
DeSantis over by taking him for granted
Tim oh is that but no actually
yeah just the kind of guy you play hard
to get with is the question like a
politician I don't want to be president
it's like we don't even want you as
president stay in Florida dude who cares
and he's gonna be like you know what I'm
gonna run even harder I've done a great
job I feel like that would have worked
for Trump exactly yeah she'll be like
well you know what maybe it would be
pleasure yeah yeah when you're president
and you vote you won't be when you're
president they let you do whatever you
want you know past executive orders
grab them by the executive order that's
right all right let's read some more
let's read some more
let's see Kyle Buchanan says a small
population state does the same thing
Florida does years before no one cares
Florida says we are doing the same thing
20 other states have have then all the
progressives freak out
it's interesting
they're a big state they are timing too
is a lot about the timing here we go
Cornelius butt knuckle says Trump and
DeSantis need to squash whatever Petty
beef they have and commit to being
running mates if either of them gets the
Republican Presidential nomination
because either way a trump DeSantis
ticket would absolutely Crush that's
true man if Pence is out and good
riddance Trump DeSantis would be pretty
powerful yeah but I feel like they're
both a-listers yeah that's the problem
it's tough yeah so who but who what VP
could Trump get without you know Pence
was bad enough the first time you'd have
to get something uh what's her name from
South Dakota
I think I think it's just a question of
them running together in the primaries
right and whoever gets the nomination
chooses the other to be their running
mate I'm not saying it would be that
straightforward you know I'm I'm sure
they would uh have a little bit of
difficulty there because that hasn't
happened though in GOP
history it used to be a while yeah it
used to be the way it worked I'm going
back to you like well not just that's
really the top two Dick Cheney didn't
run for president in 2000 did he no well
no so yeah George it can happen though
McCain
Romney and Trump all four Republicans
ran not with somebody who was also in
the primaries yeah I guess I guess my
point is that if he were to I mean it's
a question of which who should be the
president who should be the vice
president I think you just let the
primary sort that out and all right
let's read some more we got smoke rings
and Sada says Tim please make a t of
cast Castle animation Ian being sniffed
by anime Joe Biden the tarot from hxh
would be perfect
so if uh if Kent is watching you can
make an animation of Joe Biden sneaking
up on you finally you're like I'm a dude
I don't know
I know man okay just so you know
all right let's grab some uh
birthday freak says now the US Army has
debuted a cute v-tuber in order to
recruit basement dwellers and Naruto
Runners across the country semper waifu
Naruto Runners I think it's funny that
people actually would like do that you
know would run like that oh yeah there
were kids in gym class bro who would
like run around the field house like
wasn't that a joke about Area 51 like
two years ago yeah
and then what happened all of this stuff
yeah
Latin says Tim I'm in the Army and the
problem I'm finding isn't that people
don't want to fight it's that they don't
want to die for these people and their
crazy ideas and worldview everybody
listening right now who is in the Army
the Marines the Navy the Air Force Space
Force whatever it is when you are if if
I don't know if you any of you will
actually see combat for whatever reason
but when you are I want you to remember
what you're fighting for picture Kamala
Harris in your mind smiling and laughing
and you will find the inspiration to
never give up
these people hate you or you will just
give up yeah you will 100 well that's
awesome I mean that's what I was saying
earlier the people who enlist in the
Army know that these people like hate
them or the people who would ordinarily
listen the Army we're gonna hate them
we're gonna do it Mason Barnett says I
think your idea of a truthies ceremony
would be a good thing what better way to
build good culture than promoting good
truthful news and journalism what should
we do a hundred grand to the truthy
awards yeah yeah look I Tim I've been
real honest lately bro I've been real
honest lately so what we could do is
Sheamus we could do we could do like
five categories
we could do five categories like truth
and truth and news truth in sports truth
in entertainment truth and political
cartoons truth and politics truth and
freedom Tunes episodes yeah yes one
whole category just you always win no
but think about truth in politics yeah
so out of the three politicians who are
good you know will be like this person's
consistently it Rand Paul yeah and then
um for journalism obviously for for you
know arts and entertainment be video
games and movies and then we say you
know like your your honesty and your
your approach
ten thousand dollars plus an award in
the ceremony we could do that yeah it'd
be fun you'd have to make sure they're
really honest here's what yeah yeah you
have to do a Golden Ticket type thing
where these the people you're thinking
of nominating win a trip to your studio
and then you try to pull a Willy Wonka
and get them to break the rules along
the way and whoever doesn't gets the
truthy boom Oh interesting I think what
we would do is we'd have a nominating
Board of
prominent individuals who are you know
trusted and then they would determine
who they think is doing a good job in
these spaces you'd probably have to have
someone who I'll nominate you we'll just
have Sheamus pretend to be all of them
listen I'll nominate you for this truth
seeking award but you have to send me
your iTunes gift cards go to Walmart
immediately can we get Jordan Peterson
uh uh scamming people into smashing the
like button all right listen
I am with the bank and we accidentally
put ten thousand dollars in your account
that didn't belong though now were we
willing to let you keep it if you just
smash the like button it's the least you
could do without ten thousand dollars on
your account perfect there we go all
right jaycar says the truthy awards is a
winning idea on many levels it will
Encompass and represent everything the
The Independents do and uh and
emancipate the stelters of the world I
don't like the name truthy though maybe
you could find it it was a joke now okay
yeah we'll call it we should call it
true third call them
we can call it maybe like the Ian Awards
uh Daria says yeah I wouldn't join or in
my case under this Insanity either I did
my eight and a half years I'm good kind
of sad to hear it though you know said
yep
Raymond g Stanley Jr says Sagar and
Jetty today said folks who want war
won't have kids in it Wars last longer
than we think and we forget about all
the battles and people we lost yeah
World War II was a hold of World War One
many people say it was just the same War
should we should we bring back the sound
board and we'll get Sheamus to do like
uh Jordan Peterson smash the like button
a bench press that like button and a
bunch of hero smash the like button
we're gonna have to think about I mean
look if you do more fauchi for me but
you said you're holding out on me to
like get you those unions I can't afford
that well that was the last two two bits
that I did with you on freedom Tunes was
that fauci is gone he's like he's been
dumped but uh so I'm actually working
really hard uh if you guys want to
donate on patreon we're working really
hard to bioengineer a virus so that
bauchi will come back and we can do more
cartoons about him oh I think
patreon.com Freedom Tunes I've been
talking to ecohealth Alliance you know
just like I I want to do it man you know
like all everything we do here is funded
by my uh my residuals off of these
freedom to true voice over bits I have
that's true yeah yeah we need yeah
seriously JK says greatest advice to
come out of the 80s don't fall victim to
one of the classic blunders the most
famous being never get involved in a
land war in Asia correct correct that's
true
surprise mechanic says speaking of
Hassan I found out today that I work
with his brother Marat it's funny that
Hassan spends all day bashing American
hegemony but when his brother works for
the dod
yep silly white boy says jenk from The
Young Turks is debating Patrick Bett
David live on pbd podcast tomorrow at
9am Tim get pbd he's the most underrated
voices in politics today I'm surprised
Jen's doing it I've invited him on
numerous times politely and he's always
just doubled down smack talking me like
the first time invited I was like Hey
Jake you know we'd love to have you on
talk about this stuff and then he's just
like ignores it see him in parsity
screams at me yeah that happened I was
at politicon he started screaming at me
I'm like why are you yelling at me like
I don't know what's happening that's
cool he's going on it's Steve Carell in
Anchorman I don't know what we're
yelling about exactly I'm really glad
they're doing that debate I want to
watch that that's cool or whatever
they're doing I'm glad I want to get
chank more involved I don't like seeing
him angry here's what I think I think
anybody who rejects a chance at a
conversation is on is is not a
legitimate personality right so there's
a there's a lot of prominent left-wing
personalities high profile that I think
are just total grifters yeah now they
like to accuse Tucker Carlson or me or
you know us here but we invite these
people on all the time and they always
play dirty games well I will only come
on digitally yeah we saw what happened
with Crowder dude you guys aren't
serious it's not it's not a serious
question also it's literally called Tim
cast IRL yeah because people don't
that's the whole point of the show is
that we don't do digital guests and it
just doesn't work it doesn't yeah you
know and they're like will you and on
Ben Shapiro's show oh over the internet
and I was like we we filmed it and then
took the memory card and delivered it
three hours away to a data Uplink Center
because we didn't have internet and I'm
like that was his show not mine like
I've also gone on Megan Kelly from here
right you know
but that's different I also don't really
go on other people's shows in the past
few years either but we've invited so
many of these people they don't do it
Vash will do it you know
yep one of the few little Destiny that's
uh I have tremendous respect for Destiny
for coming on because he kind of just I
think he genuinely believes what he
believes for sure I just really disagree
with you know his his opinions on policy
and stuff but uh he definitely stands by
you know what he says and I think he
he's he's you know he's he'll correct
himself he defeat he he called out Cal
ringhouse properly self-defense he got
banned over it true what did he recently
get banned for I don't remember some of
Lauren Southern they were working
together he was he was debating her or
something right Lauren posted about it
which is dumb if you're on Twitch man I
don't know Amazon owns it
all right Marcus Casey says Tim Army
veteran here
resigned as Captain in 2018 when I saw
the toxic leadership mirrored in
attitude of lower enlisted us mid-tier
leaders would never condone it but glad
to be out seeing the pathetic culture
now man that's really sad I know it's
because we need people like you in the
military that is really sad that it's
come to this
yeah there was one uh let me see there's
a Super Chat I'm trying to find
Doug Hansen says Ian reservist combat
engineer here we enlist for lots of
reasons it isn't dumb it's a Pro versus
con decision many person made person by
person your elitism is close to DNC
levels I'm sorry I didn't mean to uh
imply that it was dumb I didn't say that
either I I so it's not for everyone and
my dad was clear with me that if I
wanted to be creative and do a creative
life and have a creative career that I
should not join it had nothing to do
with people being dumb it's an important
job it's defense is massively important
there's a Super Chat I'm looking for
specifically I can't find it oh well
maybe it got deleted
it was specifically one person saying
Tim never reads my super chats and I'm
like I'm gonna find that oh that's rough
well I'm trying to find it but it's
ironic
maybe it's down here at the bottom
let's go to the bottom see uh I don't
know maybe it's just gone
we'll see if we can find it
oh we're really looking all right we'll
just we'll keep reading until we see we
go oh here we go I see it we'll read it
next by the way I wanted to mention
because Ian I just want to clear the
record because you you mentioned the
thing about Lauren Southern I think this
is one article I have pulled up on PC
Gamer In which dest it says Destiny said
in a Reddit post that he thinks the band
was imposed because of his stance that
quote unquote trans women shouldn't
compete with CIS women in women's
Athletics that's what he believes I'm
not sure what twitch said back up
actually
um I wonder if we can pull him last
minute for you know conversation with
someone from the daily wire or something
like that oh that'd be fun yeah yeah all
right mad Panna says I want timcast to
start doing a weekly prepping episode
covering best firearms for home defense
how to store food the fundamentals of
growing food raising chickens or foul
for protein the basics
I'm pretty sure we could actually do
that
um because we've had uh Steve from
fortitude Ranch on a couple times and so
I don't know if he's the guy to do it
but we could probably find someone who
could go over all these base all these
basic things it would be excellent
advertising obviously for them and what
they're setting up and it would be a
cool show
all right here we go Brian Grinch I did
not miss you he says lost count of how
many unread super chats I've had I wish
Tim was nicer to Ian but I also wish Ian
said smarter things Tim look into
tactical response in Tennessee best gun
School in the world building culture and
saving lives cool beans uh it's an act
you guys I know it's confusing because
it seems real but we're on TV right now
they're good pals you say that Ian you
go watch the after show if you want to
see how it really really good no I mean
there's Ian doesn't even like graphene
the only place that's him
yeah Ian's got a he's actually British
he's like I like oil I really like oil
and the Federal Reserve is great yep yep
he's like I'm a big fan as soon as the
show ends up he puts his hair back and
he looks on a suit jacket and a tie and
he's like I'm gonna go call him call Ben
Bernanke and tell him how much I loved
his work he goes back to the
Presbyterian Church he's an elder at the
day trader yeah
it's an act in so far as it's it's it's
censored what we're doing here we go now
it's a TV show danny066 says Marjorie
Taylor green did a fox news interview
from the timcast IRL Studio a few months
back that's right it was January 5th and
you could see the the Tim cast behind
her it was great someone says Ted Nugent
yes he's awesome he's so cool love to
all right we'll grab one more here we go
Brian Knowles says got an email today
from the US Army they're offering up to
to a 50 000 bonus for joining right now
you're on point decoy voice was saying
the same thing they're like we'll also
give you another mom yeah you want to
make sure there's our signings
just please please enlist the Russians
are coming all right everybody if you
haven't already smash the like button do
it for Jordan Peterson because he smash
the like button man embody the
archetypal hero we accidentally put too
much money in your bank account give me
your iTunes gift cards and uh you can go
to timcast.com become a member uh uh to
watch our members only show and uh do it
for Jordan Peterson yeah do it for me
become the archetypal hero and sign up
at timcast.com and sign up at
freedomtunes.com It's a Wonderful
website all right you can follow the
show at Tim cast IRL you can follow me
at timcaster Brian you want to shout
anything out absolutely uh two things
good guess of the show I know you guys
are friends Lily Tang Williams she's
phenomenal she's amazing she's running
for congress in New Hampshire right now
many iTunes gift cards well she well
she's looking for 10K right now in
fundraising today's last day
huh I think you got to make I think I
might have to do Jordan Peterson
solicits number two he's calling like
Dave Rubin and Ben shapir trying to get
gift cards because no no actual grifter
no no the IRS calls Jordan Peterson and
they're like we need these iTunes gift
cards he's like oh no oh no so he's
calling his friends like can you give me
an iTunes gift card they should make it
that Jordan Peterson's an actual grifter
and so he calls his fans and gets him to
send him iTunes gift cards we are
libertarians.com uh we have lots no we
have like 13 or so shows and then my
show Brian eagleshow.com uh what we do
is we focus on winning converts not
arguments so we take I take the approach
of sales and marketing that I use in the
business world and I bring it to the
world of politics so you want to get
better at talking about the ideas that
we all talk about every single day but I
actually want people to say hey tell me
more I want to learn a little bit more
make this actually happen
briannigoshow.com right on whoa
well um so
if you have iTunes gift cards
I was like this is right on the line of
the joke being dead I wasn't sure if I
should go in on it that's what I wanted
that's what I want to promote right now
uh so I have a YouTube channel called
Freedom Tunes we upload a new cartoon
every single week sometimes twice a week
that's unheard of in this current ERA
with the way that YouTube treats
animation so go check out support the
few remaining animators few remaining
cartoonists on YouTube check it out
Freedom Tunes released a cartoon today
which was absolutely hysterical you'll
all love it it's about men competing in
women's sports and like this very milk
toast response we get from a lot of
establishment conservatives about it go
watch please I love you I love you too
Sheamus thank you for telling everyone
that you love them too that was very
nice of you I wanted to point out really
emphasize what you said about Lily Tang
Williams she's running for governor uh
no Congress Congress in New Hampshire
people can donate to her campaign yes
well today's the last day of the quarter
fundraising she's 10K behind where she
wants to be so okay go and what is it
what's her website do you know offhand
Lily for congress I believe incredible
human being she is amazing dude I love
her she was on the podcast I was like
all right this person's fantastic a lot
of great guests on the podcast
lillytangwilliams.com and by the way if
you and like I know folks have seen her
in the program but like her story is
incredible it is oh my it's terrifying
too like growing up in Mao's China is
it's such a different world which we
need to hear that story today because I
think I just it's it's a story we're not
hearing a great when there's something
so refreshing about a person who has a
spine you know what I mean like and in
fact that woman really has a strong
backbone I love her yeah I want to point
out too a research study this is from
WebMD about the calcification of the
pineal gland a research study done in
the 90s found high concentrations of
fluoride in the pineal glands of study
participants fluoride from water and
pesticides accumulate in the pineal
gland more than in any other part of the
body after accumulation they form
crystals creating a hard shell called
calcification so how can I get these
this how can I get these particles this
fluoride out of my pineal glands
calcify the pineal gland I would advise
searching up on the internet and looking
into it I think breath work honestly I
know you're going to find some weird
stuff I don't know I was doing a Wim Hof
breathing method he has beginner classes
and stuff
oh yeah you can decalcify you can do
things to help decalcify theoretically I
think I've never actually like looked at
it under microscope and seen it in real
time or anything but the breathing
methods really really helped
um I think also there are you know
endogenous ways to produce DMT and
things like that breathing stretching uh
food certain foods could probably bring
it out of you
thanks guys have an amazing evening and
uh hopefully maybe see you later on the
after show
become members
members.com you guys may follow me on
Twitter and my calm at Sarah patchlands
I also have sourpatch lids.me
and I'm gonna throw I'm just uh I'm
trying to scrolling Tim is I'm making
him researching no I'm making a maximum
contribution to Lily oh yes do it with
Tim it's amazing go in on it yes so you
went you went to Walmart for sure yeah
Tim's been to Walmart if you know what I
mean he got the car in all quotes
maximum is that can you say that out
loud it'll be in the public record if
you've got it baby
all right everybody head over to
timcast.com become become a member
because we're gonna see you all about 11
p.m thanks for hanging out bye guys